have is that let's let's not offend the
gentleman
just so you know folks if you're
listening to this today i mean for 20
minutes adam wants us to talk about
vaccine gerard says i don't want to
offend people and they've been going
back and forth adam i'm telling you
we're not going to do it we're not going
to do it today fine you're going to be
okay with that we have a special guest
we have a special guest today michael
francis if you're excited that michael
is here with us give us a thumbs up
and uh subscribe to the channel
especially if you want to see mafia
states of america because that's a
project we're going to be talking about
today michael that's it how are you
feeling i feel good yeah i'm in florida
what could be
so better
was interesting yesterday uh we're
having dinner at casa de angelo which by
the way the food ex legendary actually
they crushed it yeah they closed it at
10 o'clock we left at 11 o'clock not
once the dino complained not a word if
his name is dino it could be jose but he
claims he's from italy so you know i
think he was afraid of adam that's what
happened that's exactly what it is what
was it right next to michael he's afraid
of me no no kosher nostra
nostra that was hilarious those are my
my people that's adam's jokes uh joke
but we had a good time last night
yesterday we were at shooters
and uh i'm going to shooters to meet
with my goldman guy and then i see uh
michael there with the family i'm like
michael what are you guys doing here it
was an interesting story he had with
shooters if you don't want to share with
the audience yeah first of all when i
went by and on boat i didn't recognize
it because they redid the whole thing
like seven eight years ago but that was
the first uh date i had with my wife
she was 20 years old
and
actually i was home i had a place in
delray beach i was home sleeping
somebody said hey that beautiful girl is
there tonight you know come by so i got
dressed went down there specifically to
see her specifically to see her wow and
uh we spent a couple hours together and
the rest is history as they say
literally the rest is history yes yeah
and you've got how many kids together we
have four wow by the way
beautiful kids okay thank you great
one of them is apparently he was a
bodybuilder that's my daughter my your
daughter
she's a personal trainer
and uh you know they're all into all the
girls are into fitness my wife and all
the girls the guys were you know we're
athletes
but
by the way water skiers fun facts yes
michael
people don't believe your age just so
you know people want to check your id
because they don't believe your age
michael if you're comfortable saying it
on camera i'm good i'm 70 years old 70
years old
water skiing yesterday
in fort lauderdale yeah so you actually
went water skiing yesterday i went water
skiing i hadn't done it in a long time
but it was it was great and i wanted to
do it here in florida the water's so
warm you don't want to get out of there
i want to do a quick uh commercial for
florida how many times have you been in
the water in california you've been
living there for 40 years almost one
time and how many times you've been in
florida water one time
one i'll never go back that was like 35
years ago never go it's too cold yeah
you know and especially now i got in
here in the beach you don't want to get
out of the water water's just fine come
on now
how different is florida today versus
back in the days when the mob because
the mob had a lot of uh things they did
in florida this was a hub i mean myers
was doing stuff here back in the days
this was great to go to cuba before you
know things were shut down with the
hotel when lansky was running how how
much of a change is florida today versus
what it was back in the days i mean
there's still guys living down here that
i know of but uh it was a big spot for
us i mean when we went anywhere we'd
come to florida that was it and i had a
big you know gas operation down here i
loved it down here
but uh different today i mean
everything's different today patrick i
mean it's not the same influence the
same presence anywhere in the country
really even in new york you know there
was a time when i'm not kidding every
single day you pick up the new york post
the new york daily news there was a mob
story
now i read the new york post every
morning online
maybe every six months you'll see
something you know why is that
you know things are changing i mean you
know the the the old guard is gone the
new guys are you know staying undercover
it's not the same as it was before in
any way shape or form look you got to
give the credit to giuliani and uh you
know that whole force back in the mid
80s early to mid 80s when he really
started effectively using the
racketeering act
and put everybody away and changed
everything took the union control away
did so much damage to that life which is
i guess good for everybody else but it
was bad for the life and really so this
is back in the days when when you were
doing eight to 12 million a week how
much of it was here how much of it was
new york
well i got indicted down here we were i
think i think it was like 190 million
dollars that they indicted us for down
there we had a big operation down here i
was trying to move most of what we had
up there down here to florida yes when
you say down here what part of florida
all over broward
okay i guess
yes i just want to revisit something
that you said because i don't want to
gloss over this you said
you got to give respect to rudy giuliani
for what he did so do you respect rudy
is that what you're saying well i didn't
back then you know
tony was going to give me 100 years when
he indicted me but i do now yeah
what changed obviously just age wisdom
no listen you know he was good at what
he did he was better at what he did than
we were what we did at the time so he
got us you know there's no doubt about
it he used it look my case i don't
believe i should have been involved in
that case but he didn't frame me
there was some semblance of something
that he could have indicted me on he did
but i was i was acquitted so i beat it
and it was legitimately acquitted
but uh look you got to give him credit i
mean he was a good prosecutor he knew
what he was doing and uh i think he he
firmly believed that what he was doing
was the right thing so you can't get mad
at somebody like that well how do you
process that i mean this is his biggest
competitor you know
you deal with competitors
what does peyton manning say about brady
oh yeah what are you going to say i mean
the guy is better than you you know how
hard it is for manning to be able to
swallow it and say hey this guy you know
yesterday quote came out about uh
what brady said back in 2012.
and the guy's the question says man
how's it going to feel when you pass up
montana he says i'm not going after
montana i'm going after jordan
so think about meaning i don't care
about winning five i care about winning
seven because seven is one more than
michael then it's he did it and he did
it so by the way it's tougher to win
seven rings in the nfl than it is to win
six in the nba because in the nba
you get seven games
so meaning you can have a bad thing and
lose to eli manning twice right it ain't
gonna happen in the nba you're not gonna
have four great games yeah you know you
know what i'm saying so but anyways you
better do a quote about uh manning and
brady and then hall of fame induction oh
yeah yeah well that was uh well tommy
manning's pretty uh pretty funny
obviously everybody knows manning and uh
they were they had the matchups where
they were in the afc championship five
years in a row and one one of the
pre-games you know manning gave the uh
responsible like what's it like when you
go up against brady he's like well you
know i don't really go up against tom
brady i go up against defense and that's
uh you know so i don't think of it as me
competing against tom brady i got to
beat the defense you don't play safety
and they asked brady the same thing he's
like yeah i want to kick man exists
absolutely i see every pass he makes and
i need to make i need if he's if he goes
17 for 19 i'm going 18 for 19. that's it
that's that's the difference in
mentality that was deflection on
manning's oh for sure and against
because man by the way manning is super
competitive even from tennessee when he
came out the guys uh people forget how
good i think peyton manning was like
like yeah there he i think it was 2004
he threw 490 passes and had 49
touchdowns one out of every 10 passes he
threw went for a touchdown the dude was
unreal he was great no doubt he's now is
he connected to the mob is that what
we're going with man
there's anyone that does not connect to
the mob
well you know what i i i'm a loyal guy
but i left the team because of
management they just never put a good
team on the field for how many years so
you're a jets guy yeah what nick now let
me tell you you're an island are you a
ranger guy or an islander i don't like
hockey i'm not a big hockey guy
he doesn't like nicole yeah period
but i'll tell you what happened you know
with my work with the nfl i uh i visited
the patriots and i spent time with them
addressed the team and i became a huge
patriot fan
because i love belichick i met brady
matt patricia who is a defensive
coordinator became a good friend and
that would get me killed in new york
faster than quitting tomorrow wow you
cannot be a patriot fan in new york
that's for sure how long ago was that
visit uh about three years ago oh so
three or four years ago yeah current
height of brady everything broke my
heart when the tuna went to uh to the
patriots the tuna with the patriots just
never said ourselves yeah the big tuna
yeah
and i gotta tell you brady uh he sat in
the front row and he asked some very
intelligent questions she was uh i just
got a lot of respect for him not only on
the field and were you a yankees guy
mess guy die hard yankee fan okay
what's the scene in uh speaking of
congratulations to derek sanderson jeter
number two
derek jeter going to the hall of fame
you know who showed up to his uh to his
uh ceremony all his girlfriends michael
jordan
jordan jordan and patrick ewing showed
up can you imagine like jordan shows up
you're not even in his game he shows up
to your ceremony he's recently divorced
and like adam said where jeter goes uh
you know party trees follow what was the
scene in bronx tale where uh de niro
says mickey mantle doesn't pay your
bills
exactly yeah
that wasn't de niro that was chad's
poland
what are you crying respect
bill maherski made mickey mantle crying
yeah milky mickey mantle cry yeah that
cartoon your father can't pay the bills
that's maggie manny cart today
graded psa 10 is worth 20 million
dollars 20 million dollars three of them
left in the world bro when you tell me
these stories it's amazing i used to put
baseball cards on the spokes of my of my
yeah
bicycles not mickey mantle though no
nobody puts mickey man on the corner
i love mantle he was my idol he made me
a yankee northern dimaggio as an italian
really yeah well i was younger with
demacho mano was my you know was my guy
why though what what
what kind of a player was he like how
did he win the fans over he just you
know everything about him i mean he was
a tool player he could do everything
right if that guy
was healthy if he didn't have the knee
problem and all you know the ailments
that he had if you saw his routine in
getting ready for a game you wouldn't
believe it
but i i guess what happened i was at
yankee stadium one time the old stadium
and mantle uh hit two home runs they
were playing detroit he had two home
runs and he made two catches in center
field that i can if i close my eyes i
can see it both of them were over the
head like this right up against the wall
just kept running straight for the wall
and made that catch i don't know how he
did it he never looked back
never looked back you were at that game
i was at the game wow so you watch man
you watch mano play oh yeah yeah
my dad's been able to see many times now
you were a brooklyn guy and you liked
the yankees
you weren't a dodger guy no no no you
know why
because whenever when they left brooklyn
all i ever heard was those effing
dodgers you don't leave brooklyn yeah
everybody turned on him but my
grandmother prayed for gil hodges every
day for us yeah well
it was it was a good guy he was a good
uh manager for the match yeah michael
who's your top five all-time baseball i
mean i know this is off topic but you
said mantle so what do you what are you
doing
maze was you know amazing did you watch
me
i shouldn't match play yeah you've seen
mace play yes i mean that's well we
talked about this i know we did i'm
curious to know what he's going to say
well one of the things about me is that
a lot of people don't know so some of
the old-timers that uh that i used to
talk about 450. 600 660 home runs
they're like it doesn't even do them
justice yeah he played in the poll
grounds it was 450 to dead center and
then he went out to san francisco where
he had to deal with gale force winds
blowing in from left
yeah so field
was she was amazing so you got mantle
you got maize you got jeter i love jeter
i mean how could you okay you know jeter
was the
the player of the moment whenever you
needed something he was there november
yeah who rounds out your top five oh
gosh that's hard i mean they were for me
they're all yankees because i'm a
die-hard yankee fan but i can recite the
whole you know yankee team you know
scouring
i don't want to go into it because it
makes me sad but i miss them but uh
because i'm so disappointed in that and
now oh my god the way they're playing
now yeah george is probably rolling over
in his grave they've got no heart did
you ever meet steinbrenner i met
steinbrenner twice how was that yeah i
loved the guy
loved him i mean he didn't take any
nonsense was he off the camera like how
he is hungry great guy off camera okay
is he like a trump personality yes big
hearted guy yeah you described him right
just like trump big hearted guy
but nothing intimidated him he didn't
care how great a player you were he
wanted to get the most out of them and
he uh motivated them in any way that he
thought and it was very effective who's
the skipper he fired two or three times
billy martin and billy martial it's
great when they went out and then yogi
tried to do the same thing with yogi and
yogi said he'd never go back yogi berra
five foot eight
ten world series one of the greatest
catchers of all time i mean how could
you not like one of the greatest
wordsmiths of all time yeah comedian
yeah
nobody goes there anymore it's too busy
wait ten world series championships or
yes ten world shows joki's got ten yogi
berries
talking about having humility right
humility to move to the outfield because
elston howard was coming up
molly
that's a time when the yankees were
absolutely beloved they were they were
amazing like the whole country loved
them now it's
very polarized nobody loves the eggs you
love them i hated them i was one of them
you know you loved him but dude the late
90s were a halcyon time also man like
the the yankees red sox rivalry was just
must watch tv i cannot tell you the last
time i had my calendar mark to watch a
baseball game and i love baseball but i
can't tell you the last time when was
the last time what what team got you
interested the braves
is is it a player was it mcguire sosa
yeah it was sosa 98 uh no you know i i
look i love the game when i was a kid
the mets were like
unreal like the the late 80s mets were
like they were rock stars and then 86
minutes you got to remember ken griffey
jr the crossover appeal to ken griffey
jr i mean imagine kids today wanting to
go buy sneakers because of a baseball
player like nobody knows who mike trout
is you had to have the griffies you had
to have the sneakers the kid you had to
have the swing man like you know like
it's hard enough for these guys to sell
cleats now i mean you know you had to
have ken griffey junior baseball on
super nintendo that game was unreal you
know you were a big juan gonzalez guy
die hard die hard texas rangers fan i
was a die hard tech he was six two and a
half
two eighteen i had similar uh uh
physique similar
swing and i just love this game
i played with wongan in spring training
and i've never seen anybody hit em
batting practice i've never seen anybody
did he make you a rangers fan oh die
hard that's right yeah from 91 92
oh yeah when he came in because sosa was
a rookie win 1988-89
he was a rookie in 1990 he came i don't
know what it was second or third year he
had 28 home runs i think he even i think
sosa got drafted by the white sox and
then he got traded to the cubs
and gonzalez came in and i started
following franco julio franco was also
uh kevin brown yeah i have a very
controversial uh statement here on this
there we go steroids are racist they
were great for baseball
they really were they i don't know who
was hurt by it i don't know who these
guys were throwing 100 miles an hour and
they were hitting the ball seven
thousand feet it was it was an exciting
game they were running fast it was
hardball they used to say hardball is
back one of the greatest commercials
ever made is tom glavin and
greg maddox looking at uh michelle
pfeiffer walks past them to get mark
maguire's autograph and they go chick
stick the long ball and then step just
pumping it and they're there that's
commercial yeah
i remember chicks dig the longbow it was
just a great time for sports sosa
mcguire hugging it out but they got
those little dinosaur arms because
they're so big trying to hug each other
yeah it was it was a great speculation
he was emotional when mcguire hit the
home run he picked up his son
he comes down the place is going crazy
the home run almost didn't go by the way
yeah the seven yet it was just a line
drive to the left none of those guys
make it into the hall of fame because
we're talking steroids but bud selig's
in there cashing all that paper from all
those years but
he ruined the game with the strike he
ruined the game and then he gets to go
into the hall of fame because these guys
brought it all the way back man i think
what you're saying is let's make
steroids great again
is that what you're trying to say any
kids that are watching this don't do it
but what i'm saying is that the guys
that did do it it was a pretty fun
product to watch there's nobody that
could tell me that they watched late
nights early 2000's baseball said all
the the game's better you know you know
the whole thing when they say like hey
if i did steroids that also wouldn't
stroll olympia i'd also win you know be
a bodybuilder oh i fight the steroids
you can do all the steroids in the world
there's no way you can hit a 95 mile for
asphalt harry potter i was going to say
where's the controversy nobody has yet
proven that the steroids made you hit
more home runs
i mean really you can't say that for a
fact
yeah and that's not the steroids helped
you get stronger and helped you you know
but in the pictures
that was the other thing so there was
nothing like the pictures weren't doing
i'll push back a little bit on this when
gary sheffield hit a home run on a check
swing that's right
i do remember i got one even worse glenn
allen hill breaking his bat
and then slamming the bat down in in
chicago and the ball carries carries
carry glenn allen hill was a no that's
not to say either of these guys were
yeah doing anything anyways just like
why is every why is every pitcher now
pitching 99 100 miles an hour yeah no
it's not steroids i think it's more you
can get away more with uh hrt today uh
growth hormone than you can with
steroids it's easier to get away with
growth hormone today yes there's some
you know people the conspiracies out
there about lebron what he's on how he
takes care of his body it's not creatine
doing that you know it's not the menu is
doing that there's something that's
going on that maybe we don't know about
yeah but uh it is what it is i mean
listen i i don't mind lebron staying
healthy to play 20 plus years i think
it's better for sports yeah i'd much
rather get them 20 years in 12 years so
if you're figuring out a way to keep the
youth
uh juice going where you can like you
you're going by the way yesterday we're
having dinner i'm sitting there i order
uh what did i order everything okay no
no i ordered myself you ordered the the
the parmesan
also real quick one of the most baller
things i've ever seen in my life this is
the first time in my life i've ever sat
down at a table and the food was waiting
for us that's a carolina moment yeah
the the appetizer was waiting and then
michael his food shows up yeah and his
wife says watch him finish that and
finish half my plate michael no joe
quietly he's talking to everybody
this massive bone i don't know what it
was right triceratops he finishes that
then it finishes and he's and then
sweets comes yeah i guess i'll try a
little bit of this and then
that's gone and then the next thing you
know dessert anyway so he said something
to me in the middle of dinner he goes
yeah i i probably i get i eat a lot i
could probably eat more than gerard
that's
yeah
and his wife said you heard that michael
francis wants to go toe-to-toe with you
gerard finished the dessert took it home
on the way home he finished it and then
he ran two miles this morning on the
beach
the bus boys cleaning up the place
talking too much pat goes keep eating
your sweets
anyway can we get this guy a muffin or
something so so we got something we're
going to reveal today for the first time
we're going to show some footage today
from rudy giuliani
from mafia states of america on what was
said about mario cuomo and you reached
out to the cuomo camp to see if andrew
cuomo had anything to say about that
multiple times they they did not want to
respond it turns out he had some other
things to deal with yeah extracurricular
activities but you know we won't go
there so michael first of all why don't
we uh go and talk about the sit down
with you and sami okay
we talked about this for a while you
know it was gonna happen it wasn't gonna
happen mike sammy didn't want to do it
you didn't want to do it and then you
guys spoke and it's like let's see if we
can do it and then we had a few calls
together uh
what got you to a point to finally want
to do this i'm sure millions of people
have been asking about when is this
going to happen but what made you say
you know what let's do this sit down you
know
first of all a lot of people wanted it
it seemed you know i would get it for
some reason it was even before the
thought was even you know
moving around to to sit with him people
are saying you know what's your feeling
about sammy do you ever gonna sit down
with him we see the real deal and what
do you think about the murder i mean i
got so many sammy questions
so you know i was just i was sitting my
with my wife and i said you know maybe
i'll talk to sammy and we'll see if we
can put this together and that's that's
really how it happened
and then when we did it you guys you you
brought your camp yeah you brought his
camp you guys were in two different
you know properties we had you on this
side we had semi on this side and the
whole thing starts how do you think it
went i mean first of all we have how
many hours of footage we have uh
including the drone footage we have 26
hours 26 hours of footage
of which let's be honest seventy percent
is sam i would say 24 hours with sammy
talking
but but how did you think it went you
know i mean look i'm glad it happened
you know you know there's so much
nonsense going on in the internet right
now i mean guys are just coming out of
the woodwork you know a lot of them i
never even heard of before but
um look there was a
sammy and i were really a part of that
life on the level that we were on he was
the underboss i was a couple at that
time
and even though things you know sammy
did what he did i did what i did there's
still a certain amount of respect there
it's just you just feel it inside you
know even though we both are out of the
life he disagrees on that for some
reason he still thinks he's causing
austria i said you want to walk down the
streets of brooklyn with me and let's
see how cousin austria are but
but um why what would happen if you walk
down the streets of brooklyn well i'll
leave that up to you tomorrow
strike
some guy from iowa named todd with neck
tattoos who try to serve him milk latte
okay but i can't explain it you know
there's still
speaking to him there's a certain amount
of respect that i feel you know and i
think he felt the same for me so that
came out you know and and these
sit-downs
you know it's amazing patrick you can be
away from the life for
me now what 20 some odd years
but sometimes i'll get off a plane in
new york
and the feeling comes right back like
it's like i never left
and when i sat down with sammy i almost
felt the same way we're at a sit-down
and there's a level of respect that you
have for one another regardless of what
either one of us did and i think it came
out during that i mean he got a little
testy we both got a little testy at some
point and uh you know how to remind him
he's not the underboss anymore you know
just calm down and and he said some
things to me and we both said some
things you know at different times about
each other that weren't you know very
nice
but i think uh all in all it went pretty
well yeah i mean i i showed that
obviously there's a lot of different uh
uh
sections to the interview but there was
a part when i showed a clip with you and
mike tyson
where i asked sammy i said sammy i want
to show you video with what michael said
about you with on mike tyson just to see
what reaction would be and it was a clip
of you
saying uh sammy had uh what was it
napoleon syndrome right yeah
on his best yeah
on his worst day
gotti on his worst day was better than
sammy on his best day and how much has
that changed from that comment being
made on tyson to now after having that
two days two and a half days we spent
with sammy well you've got to understand
something you know
prior to me sitting down with sammy i
spent a lot of time with my dad
and the talk about sammy you got to be
honest was not good you know from
especially guys like my father who would
never say a word about anybody to cut
he'd rather die you know 100 deaths and
say a word about anybody so to guys like
my father sammy was a bad guy you know
why though why
because of what he did with john i mean
you know look testified against gotti
testified against a whole bunch of guys
so the word on the street with respect
to that was no good with sammy and
especially from my dad
and he didn't know sammy you know he
never met him but so he didn't have a
personal relationship with him in any
way but what he did you know on the
street was no good
so
god look god he was not an easy guy to
get along with he was a narcissistic
type of guy i got along with him when i
had to i had a couple of disputes with
him
but he was a stand-up guy at the end of
the day i mean he went to jail he didn't
talk about anybody and that was it and
on the street that matters
that matters so
that's why i made that comment you know
it strictly pertained to that
but look i got to know sammy now it's a
different story and he had his reasons
for doing that i'm not going to judge it
anymore
and
you know he's trying to turn his life
around i see how he is with his family
he's great
so you know who am i to judge you know
look
we were all on the street we all did the
things that we did maybe some guy did a
little bit more than another guy but
we're all guilty of that
and you know i've come to that you know
conclusion and realization so i don't
want to talk about anybody uh sammy and
i are different we have a different you
know way of looking at all of this and i
think it came out you know in the city
oh yeah yeah michael
prior to the sit down that you did with
patrick and gerard and obviously with
sammy how many times had you met sammy
in person how many times have you met
gotti in person prior to the sit down
well i met gotti several more times and
sammy you know back in the day
we met sammy one time that's it that was
it so this was your second time meeting
sammy in your entire life sammy was
sammy uh uh uh straight up feared like
he would sit there was he a dialogue guy
or was he a guy that would just sit
there focus on you and watch every move
and extremely paranoid skeptical what
was uh sammy known for back in the days
not today
you know sammy's got a sense of humor
he's very charming yeah absolutely great
and great storyteller
he's engaging to be around there's no
doubt about it i mean i enjoyed the time
we spent we spent several hours together
i went out towers i want to see him we
spent several hours together
um
you know look
he had a reputation on the street no
doubt about it and we heard things about
him again it wasn't my personal involved
with the involvement with him
but uh i don't want to get into all of
that now because we do get into it when
we sit down i think that's fair so let's
talk about you you brought up your dad
sonny uh uh uh we you and i met with
them multiple times we went to new york
and we're trying to do something with
them
and one time we had the whole crew there
we were at the uh the not hospital i
don't know what you would call that it
was the veterans hospital veterans
hospital we were at and
talking to him and so i'm driving him in
the car and i'm we're going to this
italian restaurant i don't know if you
remember what the name of the italian
restaurant was yeah so we go to this
italian restaurant
the lady is really nice who owns the
shop she's taking care of us being good
to us and
every time i ask your dad a question hey
sonny what what do you what was it like
what was lucky like fantastic guy
he's a great guy great family guy
lucky's got a history great guy was
always respectful how about meyer they
said he was a billionaire what do you
think was he that kind of a guy he had
money i have no i have no idea but great
guy phenomenal guy so i say how about
ben siegel how was ben another great guy
so i said sammy so all the movies are
like sunny all the movies are lying
these are great people that i dealt with
i said sunny why don't we do the
interview so you tell the world who you
were
rather than
the world telling everybody who you were
i don't want to do that why don't you
want to do that so one time i went there
you weren't there your sister was there
they were upset you know she was upset
she was like you know because you know i
think i like two or three meetings mario
was there mario pulls up
his dad looks at mario's like
who are you
marty says and by the way at 101 when we
first met him presents like a man you've
never heard him one he died at 103. just
so you know that so that's why you look
so good at 70. you're gonna go to 100
easy
his presence
unreal at 101 so he goes like this to
mario who are you
mario says
i'm i'm just i'm here with patrick he
says you a rat
martial 101 years old he says he's
asking martial friends so marty's like
no no no i'm not a rat i'm not a rat he
says you sure he says yeah he says you
know 95 percent of men out there are
rants so you're gonna rat on this guy
he's telling this to mario right on you
yeah so at this point first mean at this
point it's getting very uncomfortable
mario's getting uncomfortable and
mario's already changed his pants
[Laughter]
and then mario's like no
sunny he's a great guy he says
okay linda
linda come fix my hair come here linda
grab the comb so the nurse comes and she
starts fixing and saying why are you
doing it that way go the other way you
know how i like it you can tell the
man's
presence
on how sonny was you know i'm gonna be
honest with you i knew i was fortunate
to meet a lot of guys at that time you
know from chin to fat tony to castellano
gotti all there was nobody like my dad i
mean it and i'm not
you know i'm trying to be as objective
as i possibly can there was really
nobody like him what was your dad like
when he was you know doing his thing you
know back in the day he had and that's
why he became such a major target i mean
what nobody really understands i mean if
you're around that time you knew my dad
was the john gotti of his day before
they had you know social media and all
this kind of stuff he was a john goddard
he became such a target of law
enforcement i mean look he's indicted
four times in the 60s
media like you wouldn't believe front
page all the time and he was the guy
and it was his presence you know he just
had a presence about him back then he
walked into a room you knew you know he
was there that was it all the focus went
on him you go to the corporate i mean i
was with my dad i'll never forget we
were in the copacabana um i forget who
was playing i think was jimmy roselli it
was jimmy roselli and joe columbo came
in at that time and my father had to
tell
the waiters to take care of joe colombo
because everybody was catering to my
father you know
i don't know joe colombo he was the boss
and and i saw him do that a couple of
times where all the attention always
went to him and somebody else came in
the room he said hey take care of that
girl you know who he is you know be
respectful um he just commanded that
kind of presence if you could summarize
your father in you know three major
words is there any words that come to
mind you know charismatic um powerful
you know i mean those two words you know
and and loving i mean as a father he was
terrific
never missed a baseball game of mine
wanted me to go to college
you know just a good husband at that
time to my mom i mean he was just in in
the house he was great he loved him one
year 19 years he was born in uh 17 19.
he was born in naples my dad was born my
grandfather came here and yeah my
grandfather came here several years
earlier but he would go back by boat
every year to naples
and my father was born on a boat trip he
was one of 19 kids by the way one of 19
kids no facebook no youtube yeah nothing
else
that was one of the crazy parts about
the uh the interview frankly man was
watching two men actually sit there have
a conversation not look at their phone
for 16 straight hours
and that's that's the thing after being
with my dad and he he taught me a lot he
taught me how to navigate that life
i was never in awe of anybody else i
respected them no doubt but i never
you know gotti to me was all right you
know he's
he tries to be have that big presence my
father didn't have to try
he just wasn't who he was that was it
big difference oh yeah so there's nobody
you were in of like oh damn he's here
nothing no well let me ask you the in in
some of the movies and some of the shows
that it's been so popularized in pop
culture is that is there a character
that you see and you're like i think
they took that from from my dad i think
that guy is is is kind of playing the
sunny francis
no but i'll tell you this i think the
greatest
performance of an actor
in one of those movies was armand asante
in the gotti movie in 1996.
he was tremendous to me
i could watch that movie a hundred times
guys can you just because
good luck the guy's uh i mean
maybe one of the best looking guys in
hollywood he was in mambo kings with
antonio bonduras he crushed it the guy's
a beast of a guy and his voice judge
dredd he's got a voice you cannot teach
that voice no yeah
yeah he's uh oh yeah
start how old is he now he's about 70.
he's young
let's see what he in in that movie no
put armando asante not desante
i don't know what part of it images go
images
to see how he
is that travolta yeah travolta
it was probably one of the worst movies
i've seen in my life two hours later i
felt like i wanted to brief on my two
hours
and travolta is a great actor he just
didn't get gotti and he didn't get no he
didn't give a spike
by your friend it was a great guy go
middle middle right all the way to the
right really yeah one no one down yeah
all the way to the right look at this
good looking
no no that d by the way this this guy is
sexy
[Laughter]
but he he
well he kills every role that he's in
but he just killed that rolling god i
mean who else did he played gotti better
than gotti to pick up gerard's question
who else comes to mind other than arman
asante i thought you know next i thought
pacino in um donnie brasco because i
knew i knew uh lefty he was terrified i
thought that was his best role really
yes that and and obviously uh
gosh
we played the cuban drug dealer oh scarf
scarface and he was great man
but uh donnie brasco he was terrified i
think that guy pacino is going to do
something good in hollywood i think
something's going to come through i
think it was johnny depp's best role
let me let me go back to a couple
stories you know
with
your father uh
how how much cred i know you told you
and i have spoken about this before how
much credibility is there behind the
story of your dad with marilyn monroe
that that's out there a lot of people
have talked about that before
but how much of credibility is there
with the story of him and jackie he said
he party with jackie in florida jackie
jackie kennedy jackie kennedy him and
jackie apparently used to hang out
together you know i will tell you this
my dad sometimes embellished things a
little bit yeah but he never straight
out lied to me so he might have made it
a little bit better than it really was
maybe
but when he told me something i believed
it you know the whole marilyn monroe
story i mean
when he finally told me that was after
my mom died because i said to him i said
dad
why did bobby kennedy come after you in
such a way what happened you know and he
said to me mike now that your mother has
passed i would never be disrespectful to
her i can tell you and he said he had an
affair with marilyn monroe and then this
might have been a little bit
embellishment he said marilyn monroe was
in bed with bobby kennedy and she
started yelling my name
oh
it was it was it was the swinging 60s
baby wow and then he said bobby got on
the phone with hoover and said get
francie's no matter what you got to do
oh man and that's when all the trouble
started all he had to do was run for
another year or two he would have been
all right that was it but i mean i do
know he was with her because i said dad
he said no i'm like straight straight
school what are your thoughts on you
know jfk bobby kennedy even mlk because
that's when you were a kid and you're in
your teens what was that like in that
time cia doing some house cleaning bobby
kennedy i had to dislike because my dad
always said it was him that went after
him and put him in all his trouble
because remember hoover you know up
until that time never would even admit
that the mafia existed and the reason
for that is because one of the reasons
you know frank costello was involved
with the store club who were used to
going there quite a bit and they had a
lot of dirt on him
and we do cover this in mafia statesman
they had a lot of dirt on him and uh he
would never even admit to it until
velocity came around then he had to
admit to it but uh but he never went
after the mob yeah bobby kennedy gloves
off he went after him well uh
you guys if it's all right if i say you
and sammy both uh talked about the mob's
involvement in the jfk assassination as
well in this coming and you had said
that you two had never spoken you had
never talked about it before and you
corroborated each other's story and it
was almost the exact same story i heard
it all my life i mean why would people
lie to me about it you know from the
right people and what i what i believe
is the classified documents about the
kennedy killing will never be revealed
because the government will never want
the public to know
that the mafia got to a sitting
president that's my belief i don't think
they'll ever be unclassified trump tried
to or he was going to and then they put
a stop to it well biden just is going to
apparently going to uh declassify the
911 uh report as well so you have to
adam's point you have marilyn monroe
dying in very very uh
very
interesting circumstances
do you drug overdose yes but drug
overdose apparently after a phone call
to the white house
so
basically there were some
incorrect well it's pretty well known
that her and jack kennedy and then
jackson yeah
passed her off on her but on his brother
bobby uh because she called one night
and jackie answered the phone and it was
like a whole thing imagine that you're
the president united states and you
still got a landline there were no cell
phones back then man and you know
marilyn monroe is calling the white
house has the white house line and
misses uh
this is first lady it's just a phone
call
growing up i had a poster of pamela
anderson on my wall i was a 16 year old
kid pamela anderson was marilyn monroe
like that girl for you
no okay i mean uh you know she died in
the 60s i was still a kid okay but uh
well we'll get just to get back on it so
just real quick do you think
the kennedy's had marilyn monroe killed
you know
rumors all the time but i never heard
anything from any of my associates at
the time that that was true and do you
think the mob had anything to do with
bobby as well as jack i never heard that
either really no
only jack really so so what do you think
about sarhan sergeant you know that's
all over the news
yeah they're going to let them out
you know listen you know from a guy
that's done time and look i've either
been in prison or visiting prison my
entire life this guy did a lot of time
if he's rehabilitated and they believe
he has let him out but those of you that
don't know the murderer of bobby kennedy
and also for people that don't know
bobby kennedy was a shoe-in to be the
president united states yeah of course
absolutely the level of momentum he had
was was unbelievable
yeah and maybe even more qualified than
his brother oh definitely yeah yeah a
lot of people think his brother was the
real brains behind the operation but uh
jack just had that charisma and bobby
was what the attorney general at the
time yeah yep
well according to
bobby bobby coming down on on the mafia
according to rudy uh when colombo did
the anti-italian italian anti-defamation
league that's that was the italian
american civil rights league that was
when the entire fbi apparently was like
all right enough of this we got to go
get these guys well
i was one of the first ones called to go
on that line and that that thing started
just several months after my dad was
went to prison was that like the black
lives matter of its time was that like
yeah i mean we were a little bit more
respectful that we didn't start rioting
and looting and doing all of that well
you weren't commies no
we got a call to go down to 69th street
and third avenue and pick at the fbi
building and when i got there i mean i
was a kid i was not 20 years old when i
got there
they handed me a sign
and the sign said my father was a victim
of fbi gestapo tactics he was framed and
sentenced to 50 years in prison that was
the sign i had to carry that's not
leaving a lot for interpretation no
and that line grew from you know i mean
40 50 people the first or second day to
thousands thousands within a short
period of time i mean joe columbo
rallied the troops no doubt and
everybody on the line all the maid guys
on the line were very upset they didn't
want to be there
they didn't want to be there you know it
got so bad the fbi were so upset they
were throwing water balloons down from
from you know was throwing water water
balloons down on us on the line yeah
that's how crazy well according to
giuliani that was like the last draw
that was like the okay oh you guys you
guys want to do this okay yeah yeah and
that was not a popular move uh within
the mob circles for joe colombo let me
ask you pat
you've interviewed how many
mafia
people of that life i i don't know
anybody that i could i have yeah yeah
where did you this interest come up in
your life that obviously a kid from iran
you weren't watching the good you know
the godfather no but you did though oh
did you i mean godfather in iran was
like everybody watched the gospel wow
even in iran in farsi okay
yeah yeah tell us about that yeah so no
we grew up watching that we grew up
watching all of that and then
you know uh bronx tale carlito's way
scarface you add all of them up any one
of them
goodfellas casino there's a level of
curiosity you know what's happening
because everything in business and in
the mob it's very very similar the only
difference is if you cut somebody they
don't kill you they may terminate your
contract
they may
you know no longer do business with you
they may do whatever they can to put you
out of business which is a form of a
lawsuit but they're not going to come
and kill you right but everything else
is very similar well you heard pat talk
at the vault i mean about systems about
discipline about uh organizational
structure i mean
literally almost nobody did it better
culture culturally safety
uh how the level of respect with women
certain code you followed sisters
daughters
uh uh what so that created a level of
safety if you were in right there was a
level of safety
so if you create an inner circle in your
business and your company those who are
in it there's a level of safety there's
a level of additional benefits that
comes with that there's a
so that model is ran by a lot of
different people in business
so many similarities and then you know
michael and i uh there was a uh bill
mcintosh we got to give him credit cause
bill kept saying pat
you got to interview michael i'm like
bill i'm not doing this he says pat i'm
telling you interview michael for a year
and a half bill from peru
would follow me asking me to interview
michael and i kept saying finally we
agreed
on my way to michael's house i was
sitting with jordan belfort in manhattan
beach i tell mario mario we're late to
the next interview we're supposed to be
there like 4 or 5 4 30 or something we
show up at 6 30 and they're supposed to
go to a church function and so i'm like
these guys so mario's hey michael you're
so sorry they're on their way they're on
their way i'm dealing with la traffic
finally we get there an interview that
was never supposed to happen
at that time michael's you know
we were i don't know how many subs we
had at that time 500 450 000 some number
like that right and michael doesn't have
a lot of views online he's got 500 000
view videos 300 000 view videos he's
done some stuff
and then we do the interview
we post it we don't think much of it
next time michael's like hey patrick can
you tell me what's going on i said
michael you're on the cover of world
star he says what are you talking about
so the interview goes on world star
picked up by worldstar everybody starts
contacting us about this interview it
takes off now it's got i don't know 12
plus a million about across 13 million
views
and uh and so that led to the next
interview and i don't know who
i think we did another part to you and i
yeah
we got well
i mean listen i mean now michael's got
stuff that he did with buzzfeed he's all
over the place michael has done wired
but i don't you got everything now you
got your channel that's about to cross a
million subs you guys are crushing it
with your crew
uh there you guys got the then sammy we
did the interview with sammy
and uh sammy was uh extremely difficult
to get that done he just didn't want to
get on camera sammy didn't want to get
on camera he says you think i'm gonna
sit with you
i sat with diane sawyer in 1994 i'm
going to do one of these youtube things
now he's doing youtube right now you
can't get him off
but talk about that how did you go from
beginning 2020 to you're a youtuber how
does that happen michael i don't i don't
know honestly it's it's the cra you know
sometimes i i i'm in bed laying down at
night and i'm saying what am i doing
with this youtube
you know it's a powerful tool man yeah
it is you know you know things got real
when you said if you like that there's
another clip over here and if you like
the channel please subscribe and smash
that thumbs up what are we talking about
not only that i'm almost every other day
i go on youtube and there's somebody
else yeah you know i mean it's like you
know it's a whole genre of people we're
saturating michael it's really only two
people that are you know so
of course there is a lot but you know
when it comes down to this genre it's
two people i know john is thinking about
doing so rumor on the street is john is
thinking about doing something
uh so
no he is doing something yeah i know
he's a woodsheck mafia he's doing but i
don't know what angle he's gonna take i
don't know how he's got some people on
his team that are quality people we've
had a couple conversations with them in
the past not today when we did the sami
interview we had some exchange there but
uh
it's not going to be a camp that's going
to have a lot of people there and sami's
interviews now got 12 plus million views
so both of them so you got sammy 12 plus
million views michael 12 plus million
views he's about to cross 13. now we
have mafia states of america so it's not
like individual so sammy calls michael
out then michael calls sammy out and he
went back and forth back and forth back
and forth non-stop like michael would
say something and something but what are
you saying though what's your point with
that and then michael sammy would say
something but sammy i disagree with you
and then they so
you this like chess palminter says
patrick i don't know if you understand
this this has never happened in a
history
of uh of um
mob this has never happened so and i got
a phone call i got i'll tell you about
afterwards a very interesting phone call
that you and i will talk about uh right
after i was gonna bring it up to you
yesterday there was too many people
wrong but i'll talk about it afterwards
what happened sure very strange people
have contacted me about this interview
because everybody wants to know and then
the trailer so now people are asking
when is this coming out you know we
don't have a date yet you know we're
trying to figure out when we're going to
launch it people want it to come out
tomorrow drive me crazy
i'm sorry i don't know yeah speak to
patrick yeah it's big it's bigger than
than the mafia genre though i mean this
is this is a history this is an america
that doesn't exist i think they're going
to watch this 100 years they have to i
mean this is a time capsule this is the
what i got out of this and from the
research that we're doing from the
project man is that that this is the
story of immigrants making their way in
america you could be
the mafia is identified with italian
americans but as we got into it you
talked about bugsy siegel who talked
about jewish the the jewish immigrants
in the in the beginning in new york were
the ones that taught the other
immigrants we talked about this then
there was the irish westies and then the
the attack but nobody took it to the
level of the italians did i mean the
russians and the chinese maybe but well
no i'm going to tell you this you know
when you talk about mafia causing oyster
in this country you got to understand we
survived and prospered for almost 100
years under some difficult conditions i
mean we always had law enforcement after
us
but why because we had structure we had
discipline we had authority we had
respect among one another
and and there were some pretty
intelligent guys there you know i always
say this you know you know who made the
mafia in this country who gave us the
biggest advantage prohibits the
government yeah prohibition because of
prohibition because that's when the
money came in that's when we started
getting the money and you don't do
anything without money and you were
advocates you were advocates for the
people at that point the people didn't
want prohibition you were advocating for
the public absolutely yeah is there any
similarities to
today prohibition was in the 20s right
so now it's 100 years later
are there any comparisons today to what
the government is doing to manifest a
certain marketplace like it's bitcoin
the new prohibition like what's that
correlation because i have a russian
friend who says when the government was
we're talking about like government
overreach and tyranny and online and
everything like that he was like it's no
problem for russians we just go black
market they can do whatever they want
russian is very smart but you know uh i
you don't want to get me started i'm
writing a book i want you to get the
democrats mafia democracy because
i am telling you that our government
today is acting very machiavellian
just like the ideology that we followed
on the street and the other thing i
wanted to say remember all these other
groups i mean you got to give them
credit but you know you take the cartels
in in you know mexico south america
they're built around drugs you take
drugs away that's it they got nothing
but we infiltrated every sector of
society from the guy on the street with
the numbers business right up to the
white house and everything in between
and you know this patrick you control
the unions in this country you control
the country
today yeah that's literally what the
democrats are not really right now not
today because they took a lot of the
union power away from us but look you
control the teamsters you got two and a
half million truck drivers you call a
strike the country stops which you call
a strike at the docks nothing comes in
and out to his point what did they just
do in australia to uh to to compete
against these vaccine mandates the
truckers shut down the roads they
stopped on the bridges they at all at
the same time they shut the country down
and within 24 hours south wales in
australia went from mandatory
vaccinations to uh non-mandatory to what
do they consider what it was uh and it's
legit you call a strike it's legit they
can't do anything it should you until
until you negotiate and they reach a
point of
a conclusion but you have that kind of
power
you know in politicians you got these
huge pension funds
you know politicians are drawn to money
you know that patrick they're drawn to
money when you control that type of of
uh when you have that type of control
you've got a lot of authority who has
more power in america than the nea right
now
the education association you know the
country it's funny yesterday i spoke to
captain dennis tajer who is the
spokesperson for the largest union for
pilots in america fifteen thousand
pilots it's called apa allied pilots
association right
and he was talking about uh
uh uh the difference between union today
versus before you know how jimmy hoffa
union before versus today how different
is today's union than before has it
changed much or is it still similar kind
of influence and power
it's changed a lot because the mob
doesn't have the control over it as it
did before okay you know and the numbers
are down in the unions numbers are down
i think you know back
you know in my day unions were powerful
man we
look i had you say numbers are down i
mean percentage of americans who are
part of unions
as late as the 1960s one out of every
three americans was in a union and now i
got to suspect it's less than
temperature you know it's no because
it's it's uh 40 because almost 90
percent of all government employees are
unions there's almost no private sector
unions they're all public sector now
patrick i had control through a guy by
the name of danny cunningham we had the
security union right
we had we had security at nine nuclear
power plants in the country
now in those nuclear power plants i know
if you know at that time when a nuclear
plant closed down you had to have
security there for a hundred years what
a hundred years juana was closed why
that's what the government said you
gotta have security there for a hundred
years whoa
danny
a question for you why why were most of
you
in the mob
democrats when you were in the life
but republican or you know independent
center right you know whatever you want
to call it once you guys left the life
that's kind of interesting to me i keep
talking to guys where
you know even
leonetti you know even uh sammy some of
these willianetti is still on the a
democrat but why were some of these guys
democrats when you were in the life what
happened what changed well i think with
trump because trump is a new yorker and
he's got that way about him yeah we're
attracted to him for me it's about his
policies but i won't get into that but
on the street
we hated the republicans because they
were the law and order
party got it the democrats were easier
to corrupt
every politician that we knew that we
corrupted they were all democrats every
single one unpacked though what do you
mean by that
you know guys that we had on the payroll
guys that would do us favors guys that
got me licenses for my gasps they were
all democrats so if you if you went up
to a republican saying listen i need a
gas license what would they say to you
or did you not even we didn't do it we
didn't approach it because you knew
there's 20 democrats around to do it so
you had in the 80s what is this yeah 80s
70s 80s yeah all the way through but
dude the the start of the democratic
party with tammany hall and with boss
tweet i mean the the big the big tent
idea is you know vote early vote often
chicago politics i mean it's it's pretty
well documented man you your folks are
uh not exactly the most noble creatures
walking the place of the earth it's it's
just it's like my dad hated ronald
reagan don't let him believe your
brother ronald reagan's a rat yeah he's
a ratty you know he goes he doesn't like
italians he goes after all the mob guys
well that that's his job you know you
know you're supposed to come back oh
your dad said that to you about racism
so your dad was a democrat democrat all
the way interesting and like i said the
guys that we were closest to they were
all democrats so democrats were more
friendlier with the mob and they were
okay with looking away and letting you
do your thing so yes a hoover uh kennedy
these
these guys were like listen you guys do
as long as you do your thing and you do
us favors we're gonna leave you guys
alone joe kennedy was uh was a
bootlegger you know that he was involved
in prohibition yeah he was close with
costello and a couple of guys that knew
him well that's how this whole deal came
together with the kennedys you know i
meet esposito i mean it's it's public
knowledge now he was very close to a
good friend of mine richard givenelli
and another guy i don't want to mention
to me still around and uh you know
fritzy was with chin giganti mead did us
a lot of favors yeah mario biaggi the
same thing these guys passed on now
cuomo how much is sorry how much of this
is because for a long time the unions
did represent the working man and you
guys were the working man and the
democratic party wanted to represent the
working man and this was part of the
fabric of everyday life
so you know it's one thing that they
were corruptable but i'm sure
you know just to play devil's advocate
and and to unbreak adam's heart it's
like i'm sure like in some way there was
a wink of a nod like how much more money
do these rich republicans need how much
more money do these robber baron nixon
republicans need man so i mean it's like
what am i going to come down on the guy
that what's he doing running numbers
come on you know so i mean how much of
it was like that and don't get me wrong
it wasn't that we were selective we had
to go with a democrat we didn't care if
you're democratic republican independent
or whatever it just so happens that the
guys that were easiest to get to were
democrats you're saying that you don't
care about the red or the blue you care
about the green oh exactly exactly we
didn't care who it was right i'm
interested in that in the structure you
talked about before because you you know
you talking about
the the way that you guys were able to
build out the way that you were able to
build out infiltrate all parts of life
you guys had this corporate structure
the commission was one of the first true
c-suite boards in america
but you guys don't have i'm assuming you
don't have user manuals and there's no
orientation you know not you're not
going away on a weekend trip today
eventually there was a user manual the
eventual was a user manual and that's
what they used to come after them
was the user manual so he gave that up
to everybody so for years before that
how how was the structure passed on it
was just word of mouth or i can't
imagine there was a mafia orientation
congratulations on being a maid man come
this way and we'll teach you day one on
what's code red in the marines
i only know because of one of my
favorite movies of all time and i'm
assuming it's a sick movie right but
code red was a real thing for a long
time but was it really of course it was
wow but it's not something that you talk
about right there's a lot of things uh
you know i don't know who i was talking
to michael that said
you know the best guy he dealt with i
don't know if it was sugar man i don't
know who it was and one of these guys i
spoke to
he said uh
the best gangsters were the ones like
meyer lansky never wrote anything down
on paper
he was a even harvey keitel when they
were the movie he talks about it in
there says never write anything down on
paper everything was here exactly the
guys that did it right they tracked like
if they knew this guy owed him 10 grand
or 20 grand
it wasn't written anywhere like an excel
spreadsheet hey uh you know mr director
of uh it was like hey you know what you
did last month where's that ten thousand
dollars what do you mean ten thousand
dollars well you know i know what you
did
so it was a lot of memorization the guys
that did it right so so you you almost
had to have a certain skill that's not a
duplicatable exactly
i want to tell you this and and this is
the god's honest truth i never wrote
anything down before i went to prison i
would never forget a phone number i
would never forget who owed me money i
never forget a name never at that level
that much money and never never never
forget anything
when i went to prison and this is the
truth
so many guys would hit me up with deals
and stories and this that i would yeah
yeah yeah i would let it go one in one
ear one out the other when i come out of
prison i couldn't remember a name or
phone number or anything else
and it stuck you were locked in you were
in the zone locked in but back in the
day well you know you know what my
father talked about right my father used
to tell me the the telephone is a cop
that's how you look at the phone when we
were in my house in rosalind long island
yeah my dad wanted to talk to me when he
was on parole he's come on let's go we
need to take a walk and he would talk to
me like this like a pitcher on the mound
talk to me like that or we would go into
the bathroom he would turn on the
faucets we would lean our heads into the
faucet and he'd be standing there
flushing the toilet to make sure that
nobody can hear anything he ingrained
that in me
i never got caught on a wiretap i never
had any of that stuff that i had to
worry about because i looked i was not i
don't want to use the word paranoid it
was extremely careful has any of that
stuck around till today or no like you
know how sometimes you know like i was
born in iran so if i hear a certain
alarm like it takes me straight back to
iran if i hear a certain noise is it
still in the same way
i hate talking on a phone i i still
don't like it i just i'm not comfortable
with it if you live that life there's
someone that's just on your cell phone
you don't yeah i don't like to talk on
the phone you see my very few phone
calls his dad is saying the phone's a
cop and everybody is like hi cop what is
the name of you're using seriously
but you made a comment about mario cuomo
kai do you have that video about mario
como what you guys talked about as well
as what giuliani said about mario como
if you have that
i i wouldn't mind because when we were
sitting down go ahead no it's great
great baseball player as well mario
cuomo for people that no no he was a big
yankee prospect that got one of the
biggest signing bonuses of all time at
one point but by the way he was a guy
that was loved and admired by a lot of
people a lot of people from both sides
based on what you read about the guy
respect it so i asked you guys about
mario como comments came up it was not
necessarily intentional just kind of
came up and uh you guys both said maybe
if you want to share you guys both
talked about how mario's involvement it
was you know yes
in the mob it was
he he was friendly with guys on the
street yeah so so here's what rudy said
about mario cuomo kai if you want to
play it it's uh
uh by the way uh
yeah and with rudy we sat down for three
and a half hours at his place if he
could have he would have captured her
all day
oh and if we release what what giuliani
said oh i don't you know like some of
the stuff that julia maybe that may be
episode 8 9 10 that people have to watch
it but some of the stuff that he says
it's gonna be yeah uh uh uh it's not
gonna be good for some folks out there
so but go ahead play play what giuliani
said about sammy the uh
many names were brought up so i asked
him i said who was easier to
bribe you know when you were a mobster
was it the republicans the democrats who
was that they said not even close it was
always easier to bribe and buy you know
democrats i said give me names who
anybody that maybe you work with they
can talk about we started kind of going
through a list of names they spoke very
favorably about mario cuomo governor
mario comey yeah i would too yeah and
they they said very good things but they
also said we had them in our pockets and
you know meaning you know
so you they hadn't they had they had
they had him in their pocket
somewhat because of his own um
of his own limitations in his thinking
and somewhat because of his wife
so his wife's family
and i hate to say this because she's a
lovely woman i think matilda is a just a
grand lady but this is part of the
italian experience had mafia connections
and the governor was always afraid that
if he ran they would be exploited
and i owe and i i opposed
mario in the sense of my political
philosophy was really different than his
certainly at that point in my life
even though i endorsed him for governor
well i'll explain why later i needed the
money
for the city
um
all you need to know i don't think
i know i know and really can't quite
describe in detail to you wouldn't be
right the details of it and it's not
nearly as serious as
he thought it was
i mean it's the kind of thing you could
easily explain as had nothing to do with
matilda
had nothing to do with mario
and it's the kind of thing that happened
back in those days when
you had to conduct a business and if you
didn't play ball with them
you were gonna
they were victims they weren't
they easily could have been interpreted
that way that's the way i interpreted it
but he he
he saw shadows about it you know how
sometimes people are more embarrassed
about something than they should be i
always thought that was the case with
mario largely because he was very
ethical and a very good man mario was
yeah very very good man and uh someone i
respected great even though
even though i thought some of his
political ideas were outdated that whole
thing about
you know there's two americas one for
the rich one for the poor i think well i
think that ended during the depression
and
uh
i didn't think if he ran he would get
elected
i thought he could be nominated but i
thought his message was too
i agree with him yeah i definitely agree
with him i mean he was uh
he was a friend to us
i put it that way
unlike his son
oh
angel he's he's it's good to know though
that he actually isn't uh you know abuse
of her hands he's just italian so
there's that
who knows andrew cuomo that's what he
said he didn't he didn't know he didn't
abuse any of those women he's just
italian what happened you know what his
downfall really was he's a bully
and he turned everybody against him
andrew yeah andrew andrew he's just he's
an abusive type of guy
he wasn't well liked he had some loyalty
that he bought you know just people
around him but
at the end of the day when you're a
bully and you mistreat people like that
the tide is going to turn yo now some
may say michael trump is a bully okay
you know would you would you say because
the the argument could go from the other
side well trump bullied a lot of guys as
well to on his way up but but you know
what the people around trump really like
him
interesting the poor manafort yeah the
corey lewandowski's people that were
close to him they like him look you say
what you want about trump
i believe trump really cared about
america
he cared about it and whether it was his
ego whatever it is that he wanted to be
the best possible guy he can be in there
for the country i think that's what he
wanted to be whatever motivated him i
don't know but i feel he he really it
really meant something for him to do
well for the country for america that he
believed in and i that's why i supported
him would you have been able would you
have been able to accomplish what you
accomplished in in the gas cam without
mario cuomo's help
yes because my the licenses i obtained
were not through cuomo okay with
somebody else
but uh i needed those licenses and they
were tough to get and he was able to i
was able to get him and that's what
that's what kind of separated me from a
lot of the guys because i had 18
licenses
so you you couldn't
unless you indicted me and put me in
jail you couldn't stop my business
can i say this is a little off topic but
i think it's very appropriate for this
segment you being a new yorker we just
saw
rudy giuliani we talked about the
cuomo's pat's first day in your
financial career was the day before 9
11. it's this weekend it's now 20 years
no saturday so two days ago tomorrow for
me it's going to be 12. gotcha 20 years
so you being a new yorker we're talking
about rudy i'm just opening up for
conversation it's a 20-year anniversary
of 9 11. we just left afghanistan it's
all over the news
just there's no specific question but
just what comes to mind when when you
when you you know
circulate through all these stories well
listen because i just saw rudy i mean
i i gained a lot of respect for him as
mayor of new york
because he brought that city back
you don't know what he was america's
mayor yes and you don't know what new
york was like prior to that you know
i'll tell you a story i was uh i was out
on i forget if i was
you know i got busted on a parole
violation and i had been out of new york
for several years
and they would drive me back i had to go
in front of judge
henderson morrison here so i was with
the marshals in the car we're driving
back
and i said hey guys what time we got to
be in court he said we got a couple
hours i said do me a favor he said what
i said let's drive around i haven't seen
the city in a while i said he says what
do you want i said i want two things i
want dunkin donuts because i haven't had
that
you're a starbucks guy what's going on
no i was done condoning this all the way
i says and i want to drive through
manhattan i haven't been here
and
when they took me down to times square i
could not believe you know the
reformation
yeah
the homie yeah this was uh right after
you know julie giuliani got into office
he was there a couple of times dude my
father wouldn't let my my mother bring
me and my sisters to the city oh it was
horrible
you know that you could get off the
bridge on houston street and i am not
kidding if people of my age know you
would have a hundred prostitutes coming
up to the car right on the street coming
up to the car rolling down your window a
hundred of them every single day
it was smut city it was just terrible
times square you you didn't even want to
go to the theaters it was all peep shows
you know now the main peep show now is a
nypd uh you know department there but it
was terrible
and the reformation of times square
alone what he did there and to clean up
the city the city you know when when
dinkins was the mayor it was it was a
party for us because anything went yeah
anything what we were doing but it was
just a terrible place the bronx was
burning in the late 70s
bronx was the worst city in the country
terrible what comes to your mind pat in
regards we're talking about 911 new york
your 20-year financial career everything
listen i so i had the uh by the way
david if you're listening to this the
david you david david david we got to
make sure that uh captain uh uh tajer
goes out on 9 11.
okay uh just make a note of that because
the captain of the spokesperson of uh
apa that's got to go out on 9 11.
got it yeah because one of the things i
asked him i asked him a few different
questions so this is the guy that's
always on msnbc cnbc on cnn on follow-up
guy he's everywhere okay yeah captain uh
uh tayger is his last name captain tajer
i think it's dennis tager yeah dennis
tager
he's a he's an absolute stunt of a guy
okay
and we were having a conversation he
said i asked him about hey so tsa
numbers are up it's only 10 down from
what it was in 2019 so people are
traveling again
uh you know should we feel safe travel
again a lot of private jet businesses
charters taking off right now are you
worried about he says no i want the
wealthier to get wealthier because the
more money the rich make my business
takes off so i'm like very interesting
as a union guy to say something like
that
and then we went and talked about uh a
few other things and then finally i
talked to him about 9 11. i said so uh
question for you in regards to 911 do
you worry with what happened with uh
uh afghanistan uh with the taliban that
another 911 could potentially happen
and and if yes how are we prepared for
it you know what is difference between
today and then i mean obviously we know
tsa george bush came out with tsa
november of 01 two months after an
illinois camera we didn't have tsa
before it was just kind of like you went
on a flight i don't if you remember it
was a lot
smoother you didn't take two hours to
prepare to go on a flight boom you went
out you could also go to someone's like
if your friend was coming
right pick them up you don't have to go
through tsp very different but now some
people say it's good some may say it's
bad the reality is it's longer to get on
a flight but at the same time it's safer
right so you're going through it much
harder to do a romantic gesture yeah
sure so i said so how much harder is it
today to conduct a another 911 and he
started talking about stats he says
first of all there's certain things that
we have on every flight that i can't
tell you about now you need to know on
every flight there's a federal agent and
you walk through it on
certain investments on every single
flight there's a federal agent he says
on every flight there's a federal agent
wow is what he's saying now whether
that's true or not maybe it's not maybe
it's my misunderstanding the way he said
it is there's a federal agent on every
flight
and then at the same time they have a
method he says but there's one thing
that he was pissed off about that he
wanted them to pass the bill and the apa
is right now doing something to pass the
bill is for every one of these planes to
invest ten thousand dollars to create
another layer of protection in case
somebody decides to
do something so they can have 10 minutes
to be able to prevent the
whoever is trying to take over the plane
for that to not become a reality so
there's one other layer that he wants to
add to it but he says look i'm not going
to lie to you we are paranoid like you
wouldn't believe we still worry about if
another 911 could happen or not so you
ask that question for me i think in the
last three weeks it just became more the
person if they're odds in vegas where
you can bet on another 911 happen in the
last three weeks it went up
it went up you know how all of a sudden
hey the lakers traded and they picked up
you know uh uh anthony davis the line
just went 21 to 3-1 okay so if you bet
the week before your head the line of
today another 9 11 happened uh went
higher yesterday we're having dinner and
your wife says i'm not traveling on 9
11. i just feel weird traveling on 9 11.
you know now what she also said it could
be the safest day of the year if you're
traveling because everybody's more
paranoid but still that thought is there
that i feel the same way yeah so you
wouldn't travel online i'm not i mean
i'm here i'm not going home
would you want your wife your kids your
family traveling all night not if you
want peace of mind no i don't think
that's something that doesn't give you
peace of mind traveling on 911 right i
think but i i would actually probably
think that we are on red alert on 9 11
20 year anniversary everything's on
reddit i don't know i don't know if i
don't know if i buy that because let me
explain to you everything about how the
how to afghanistan experience was
handled it was so sloppy
to me it says everything else is sloppy
i had a
call the other day when i see suite
executives and we were talking about
something i told a couple of our leaders
i said i said
success softens people up right
so when you win and you're like oh my
gosh i just made a million bucks yeah i
just made 10. you get comfortable buddy
and when you get comfortable and
arrogant
you are officially
exposed and somebody can exploit you
if i'm an enemy and i don't like america
matter of fact if i'm an enemy and i
hate america okay if there's ever been
an administration
that is handling things in a sloppy way
that if you wanted to do some damage to
america unfortunately
unfortunately this is the season yeah
unfortunately because you're sitting
there with your opponent you're like
dude what is the matter like imagine
you're dating a girl
and and you go to a girl a girl's house
and you want to meet her dad and you see
the dad he's like i'm sorry what's your
name i'm adam okay what do you do for a
living
i'm in school do you have a job yeah i'm
18 years old uh you going to school i am
what are you majoring in i want to be an
accountant why do you want to be an
accountant my dad's an accountant uh uh
so tell me about some of you tell me
about your mom and dad uh my mom's a
nurse my dad are they still married
they've been married 22 years do you
have any siblings i have a sister okay
good so he goes through a series of 45
questions like what the hell is wrong
with this guy right and then he says i
want you to meet my son then a 28 year
old son shows up how are you adam i'm
john shakes your hand hey this is my
sister it's my only sister i just want
to make sure you know that if anything
happens to my sister whatever you do to
my sister i'm going to do to you just so
you know that okay great so you leave
right now you go to another girl's house
you go in oh hey adam mary told me about
you you want a drink you want me to get
you something you guys have some fun
tonight grab the keys
you as a boy who has one thing in mind
you're saying what dude slam dunk i
don't need to worry about the dad with
the second girl or a brother but the
first one if i do something the dad
and the brother is going to come after
me i'm not doing nothing with jackie but
hey mary let's go out i don't have to
worry about you
jackie is biden
that's america today ain't nobody afraid
today and that's a scary thought
um that's a scary thought yesterday
uh trump was on who's the late night guy
gut feel what's uh
yeah gut feel
and they were talking to each other and
gutfield asked a question says look i
was never a fan of you and he says i
never supported you gutfield because he
said a lot of bad things about him says
no i understand i said but i think maybe
eventually you started liking me and
maybe even loving me to say i don't i
don't love you maybe there's operation
phil's talking to who uh trump yeah so
they're talking face to face and then uh
uh
uh gutville asks do you think it's
important for us to for uh the enemy to
fear the leader he says i don't know
about fear i think it's about competency
and respect
i don't know if the enemy is sitting
there saying these guys are competent
enough to handle
uh 9 11 next 911 so how could that
concerns me a lot in regards to the vice
president who can't get asked even a
semi hard question without breaking out
into some sort of maniacal laughter
cackle like she's the joker got jen
sackey coming out yesterday saying
there's going to be new mandates and uh
she gets asked a really simple follow-up
is this going to have an effect on
everyday american people and she looks
like the grinch furrows or brows and
goes only the unvaccinated
like this is what we're dealing with
like it's it's like comical it's like
the villains have taken over gotham it's
almost like on the comic book you know
what patrick people ask me you know
you're a staunch republican i'm not a
staunch republican i'm for who i believe
is going to be the bet do the best job
for the country you know i have to say
this
this is the worst
leadership in my lifetime by far
i mean not even close that's great you
live through carter i mean that's yeah
that's a big statement these people
appear to be so incompetent they they
can't get out of their own way it's
scary
i really you know i was thinking about i
was going to put something together you
know in the opening line of the gotti
movie it's it's brilliant where amanda
sante is in jail he's talking to a guy
through the uh glass and he said 20
years from now they're going to miss
kazanostra 20 years from now they're
going to miss john gotti it's like i
want to flash back and say three years
from now they're going to miss the
republican party three years from now
they're gonna miss donald trump
not because of
just because of the way he ran the
country that that's it you know and i i
it drives me crazy republican democrat
you gotta put the guy in that's doing
the best job for the country that's it
it's not a question of per for me it's
never about personality
it's about policy
that's it what's best for my country for
my kids and my grandchildren that's what
i look at
i went i went to a uh oyster place in
boston we walk in
hostess shows up gives an attitude to me
and mario
i said to her i said you know what i
said you're not a hostess
you may be a good person in the back you
may be good at handling accounting you
may be good at monitoring stuff on
camera to see if anybody's stealing
anything
you may be somebody that can do a lot of
other things you were never meant to be
a hostess
so i said don't take this as don't be
offended by this i had an assistant once
a guy's name is huten good looking
persian kid
the worst assistant i ever had i love
the guy till today he knows that i talk
about him so i said hutan i got good
news i got bad news for you he says
which one do i say which one do you want
he says i want the bad news i said
you're a terrible employee and he says
why i said i said i'm your assistant he
says i'm telling you what you need to do
for me i said this is pathetic
i say you want the good news he says
yeah what's the good news i said the
good news is you're a butterfly you're
free go do whatever you want to do says
god i'm so glad you said this because i
want to go
surf every single big wave around the
world you did that for seven eight years
happiest kid alive met a girl introduced
me to her when i was in santa ana they
got married he's the happiest camper out
there what's my point here
joe biden's not a good number one he
could be a good number eight a good
number five i think i'm sure 43 years of
experience is going to give a lot of
insight here's what happened here's what
happened fine he's not a good number one
there's a very big difference between
being a number five a number eight a
number one people learned a long time
ago you could not win a championship
building around carmelo anthony as great
as he was
you cannot win building around certain
players this was a topic with my friend
steve avedyan and he would say i would
say i think you can build a team around
russell westbrook he says you have no
clue what you're talking about i said
what are you talking about he says you
cannot build around russell westbrook to
win a championship he needs to be a two
or three for you to win a championship
look at the way this guy broke and by
the way this argument was seven years
ago
six years ago who's right he's right so
i don't know i think we forget that the
number one job
isn't everyone's job we have to come up
with a criteria on what it is to be
number one and as much as i understand
well you know he's a nice guy he's cool
he's this he's that
when you're running a country let's say
as big as it is today and you got people
who hate you because you've been
dominating for such a long time you do
not want to be a have a guy that's
leading that that's a softie that isn't
a bit paranoid that doesn't have the
energy that doesn't have the audacity to
sit there and ask and answer the tough
questions you need somebody that can
lead that it's not everyone's job
there's actually one of the most famous
quotes in uh the sopranos about that
tony soprano is getting into christopher
mossanti's uh getting into him and james
get the late james gandolfini was
phenomenal on that role and he basically
says exactly that he's like you have no
idea what it's like to have to make all
the decisions no way and then at the end
of the day after you made them you've
got to live with them and you and you
alone is that something that you'll
never have to do do you remember at the
end of last dance when michael started
crying
do you know that scene where he's like
you know what
you know you don't want this life you
don't want this life there you didn't it
is what it is and i wanted it i wanted
her to win he says we need to take a
break he just got up and walked out yeah
and i just felt that right now my body
just even
thinking about that entire scene right
look
everybody wants to be a number one until
they're number one and they say i
don't want to be a number one heavy
heavy the crown it's not everyone's job
that was a heavy the head that wears if
you go to smithsonian they show the
whole evolution of what happened to uh
lincoln i don't know if you've seen that
in in the from the first year he got
elected to like second year 30 or 40 if
you've never seen that is yeah it's not
everyone's job
he was doing a civil war i mean and and
that's a real tough time to be a
president where he was going trying to
find his own until he found his general
grant he met clement he couldn't count
on he couldn't count on any of those
guys but it's not everyone's job to be
number one well michael you said
something before about you know you
don't care about whether it's democrat
or republican you just want the right
person for the job and what you were
talking about before adam what i
remember most about 911 uh is right
after it happened you know i grew up in
the shadow of the towers towers are
beautiful the freedom tower is gorgeous
don't get me wrong but there was just
something about those two towers sitting
at the end of the at the end of the
island there and i grew up 15 miles
outside the city we saw him come down
and in the in the carnage in the
wreckage my uncles were in their
firefighters and and you know my both of
my uncles and my grandfather local 40
they they worked on towers they built
them and then they were part of the the
cleanup
everything was gray it's it's a
devastating picture you look at it when
when the towers come down there's so
much ash you actually can't tell who's
black who's white you can't tell what
race you or you're just it's people that
they look like they just got through a
12-round fight they're walking around
like my god what just happened and then
10 days after to kind of put a bow on
this we started with baseball i was at
uh i'm sorry it was i think it was 13
days after
we went to a funeral for my dad that
worked in downtown and we went to a
funeral and then we went to a uh to a
met game after against the braves and
had this massive comeback and piazza hit
a home run and it was like
i don't know if uh if anybody ever sees
it or goes on youtube watch piazza's
home run
place your own creation ah the whole
country you had sammy sosa
running with the uh
sorry the uh the flag it was amazing
there was no democrats there was no
republicans
no white no black we were americans we
don't have that today
they we kept saying never forget man 20
years later we forgot dude and it's not
only that the democratic party today is
not what it was 20 30 years ago it was a
legitimate party today you can't even
call it democrats anymore progressive
liberal left whatever it's a different
party the party of john f kennedy and
prior to that different than what it is
that's not what your country could do
for you that's what you could do for
your country democrats saying that that
today got it you know not just gave 10
bucks and he says pat you pat you're a
warmonger just because we left
afghanistan does not mean 911 will
happen quite the opposite also 60
israelis were arrested on 9 11. stop the
bs okay
so 60 israelis
arrested on 9 11. so the meaning they
they also had some level of involvement
and us i will tell you this and we've
had an assam before when you talk about
palestine he's palestinian you remember
anas when he talked to the other uh
israeli and they were going back and
forth with the whole okay uh challenge
so we know the optics of where nasa's at
and us this is what i will tell you i
have no desire to be in afghanistan we
should have never gone the first place
we understand there was a business
element to what happened in afghanistan
there's a lot of money being made in
afghanistan a lot of nice contracts that
was being made in afghanistan i don't
know i don't know the details too but
some of the conspiracies don't sound
like conspiracies they sound like things
that actually could have happened and i
give it some credence what i care about
is sequencing i said it yesterday on
facebook i don't care about staying in
afghanistan i care about sequence and
when a leader gets sloppy
and is not competent to know what are
his next 5 10 15 moves on leaving
afghanistan you can give 10 different
leaders and tell them we want to leave
afghanistan we're going to do a case
study right now you and your team go in
that room you and your team go in that
room you and your team go in this room
in the next two hours i want everybody
to come out with one spokesperson of
each camp talk about what is the best
most optimum way to leave afghanistan
ready go to your teams everybody goes in
their offices two hours everybody comes
back johnny has a team number one team
number two team number three and they
say here's what i think we need to leave
afghanistan then the person that's
moderating that group says i think the
best plan was given by three seven and
nine let's map out the 15 moves your
move number three could be catastrophic
that's the mistake this isn't about us
staying there the mistake is sequencing
and sequencing only happens
in the wrong way when the leader is
casual no energy afraid and hides that's
the problem what happened with
afghanistan's 100 sequencing problem and
that's why now we have to hear all the
stories 83 billion dollars of equipment
that was left behind to those guys for
what
why why would military go first why
would they not go last so so this isn't
a conversation about you know uh all the
other methods while they're demanding
3.5 trillion dollars in new and now
human infrastructure they just leave 90
billion behind the administration is
asking about well hey the taliban you
don't have enough women in your
administration what the hell are you
talking about like what are you talking
about what does that matter do you even
think they like do you think they care
do you know how they view women in the
country where i came from like how do
you think these guys view women if you
only knew
if the if if the left only knew how they
treated women and the lgbtq community
you would fully be on a different side
if you know how they treated gays
lesbians and women in the country uh
with all this mess that's taking place i
mean patrick you know what that is all
that is is a deflection
you know they're pandering to their base
trying to get women on their side
deflecting what's really going on there
that's what they do all the time
everything is a deflection you know it
it's mind-boggling that some of the
things that you just said the chaos that
was there i i can't understand it i i
don't know afghanistan now yes
well can i say one thing there's no
right because obviously we've been kind
of going down a path here let me just
put some facts out there and this might
be controversial whatever
we're leaving afghanistan okay
i think even the left
or i don't even like using left or right
i think even mainstream media is calling
out biden for how sloppy this is
certainly it could it could have gotten
better
different perspective
obviously we all want to bring americans
home
have our allies be safe
short term it's a show
long term though
who do we really need to be focusing on
not so much the middle east anymore we
need to be focusing our attention on
china just double the troops size in
syria dude okay hear me out here
they took the troops out of the cast and
they moved them to syria okay it's not
like they came home but the big picture
is we need to be focusing on china
and
you know a problem in our government is
we can't walk and chew gum at the same
time i know we've got 800 bases all over
the world the real problem these days is
not the middle east it's the far east so
if it takes getting ugly and messy in
afghanistan in the short term for a long
term to wake up and say
china's the real threat these days
china's the real enemy
long term there might be some major
benefits there so that's just a
different perspective nobody's happy of
what's happening in afghanistan right
now but then again for the last 20 years
nobody gave two shits about afghanistan
we all wanted to get out of there
so like i said on a couple podcasts ago
it's very easy to get into a war it's
very ugly and hard to get out of a war
especially when it's profitable you
don't want to get out when 24 trillion
dollars are spent in 20 years and 21 of
that 24 trillion go to private defense
contractors
and now it's going to be someone else's
mess to clean up yes again an ugly exit
but now pakistan
china
india russia this is a regional
situation we have the luxury of having
two beautiful oceans one that's very
cold on the left side one that's very
warm on the
on the right side to you know secure our
borders whereas in the middle east and
in the far east it's all intertwined and
it's this is china's problem now or
india's problem or pakistan's problem
thankfully hopefully long-term not an
american problem hey the problem is
though you know i i think it was a lot
less of a problem before this chaotic
exit that we had and now it could be
another breeding ground for terrorism
and you got to understand this and
patrick you should bear me out they
don't hate anybody as much as they hate
america
that's agreed
so i think and they're just whether
we're there or not there they're still
going to hate us yeah i understand that
they have more power now
they have more leverage okay we can
still be
we can still take down terrorists like
we've been doing for decades and decades
and decades without having to build a
nation we were never going to rebuild a
democracy in afghanistan it was never
going to happen let me let me ask you so
whether we said we're leaving on this
day or this day or just kind of like
leave in the middle of the night
taliban's not going anywhere you guys
have both
ran large companies you guys have both
been in charge of hierarchical
structures right when you look at your
competitors and you see them mishandling
situations like this
does something go off inside of you is
it like blood in the water for sharks
and you say okay we need to exploit this
while it's happening now is this
something that catches your attention
when you're when your competitors are
fumbling the ball this bad or or is this
something where you say you know
what's the what's the greater play here
like maybe maybe there's a greater
strategy at play oh for me absolutely
especially on the street when you see
weakness in in your competitor you
strike that's it 100 percent
sun tzu says when an enemy is about to
make a big mistake to fall get out of
their way okay
so which means uh just you don't even
need to get in the way they're gonna
they're gonna yeah now in sports
never stop an enemy from never
uh what do you call it they uh what it
what is an interception called it's
called the turnover never let a turnover
go to waste like you see how a guy you
got possession do something about it
capitalize you screwed up right so you
know the whole atlanta falcons against
brady the year they were supposed to win
i said what the hell you guys doing you
just keep giving 15 plays that could
have gone the other way
too he's like and they were passing what
the hell are you doing
so i i don't think there's a right
answer i think it's all on situational
of where you're at in a situation like
this i agree with you by the way nasa i
heard your second comment this is pat
now that you said it this way i agree
with you but going back to what you said
uh adam i agree with you uh because
here's where we're at here with the
entire situation so
the number one enemy in the world for us
is soon number one china okay china the
democratic party some people some people
well first of all no you know alexander
said i have so there's no there's no
difference in the
alexander said i have met the enemies it
is i alexander said i have met the enemy
so america's biggest enemies themselves
but let's set that aside after us being
our own worst enemy
then it's who china taliban came out and
said our biggest ally is who china china
something very strange happened this
week by two personalities
that
you know when you think about ray daly
or george soros you think george soros
is what he's the biggest funder of
antifa he's the biggest founder
you don't think about george soros who
would say let's be careful with china
but here's what happened this week very
interesting
one story is a business insider story
about ray dalio whom i interviewed one
of my favorite interviews that i did
hedge from billionaire value says
investors shouldn't ignore investing
opportunities in china even after the
recent market turmoil business insider
billionaire investor rate value told
bloomberg that opportunities in china
singapore can't be neglected it's a part
of the world that one can't neglect and
not only because of the opportunities it
provides
but you lose the excitement if you're
not there
dahlia said when asked about his family
office plan in the region and so our
objective is to be there both
economically and investment wise this is
ray dalio then george soros comes out
and it's a cnn story he calls that ray
dalio george soros calls out blackrock's
china blunder the billionaire financier
philanthropist thinks blackrock has made
a huge miscalculation on china blackrock
recently started offering investment
products to individual chinese investors
as the country's first entirely foreign
owned fund management from basaro
slammed the move claiming the company
appears to misunderstand president xi
china soros highlighted g's recent
crackdown on private business which she
sees as proof that the regime regards
all chinese companies as instruments of
the one-party state he also referenced
an enormous crisis brewing in china's
real estate market in xi's effort to
redistribute wealth these trends he said
do not augur well for foreign investors
soros also thinks that blackrock's
initiative is a threat to democracies
because the money invested in china will
help prop up president xi's regime which
is repressive at home and aggressive
abroad very confusing for soros to make
a comment like that about china who
would know better than him
who would know better than him who would
know better than that but but for him to
say
stay away from china
that's uh you know you mentioned
something earlier really really a droid
about the inner circle having special
yeah
this to me reeks and that's the pure
speculation but this to me reeks of a
guy who was promised a seat on the inner
circle did everything he was told to do
funded everybody he was told to fund
and didn't get a seat on the inner
circle that he was used that he was
never going to be a part of it you think
this is a direct thing between him and
dalio or him in the current
administration i think it's somebody
that tried to get in
to bed with g
and then found out who she really is and
this is this is the truth of the matter
and this is something the whole world
has to understand that's actually not
bad about who xi jinping is by the way
that's actually not bad
xi jinping
is going he is going
to take over the world or he is going to
die trying people do not pay attention
to what's coming out of china they do
not pay attention when this man speaks
xi jinping is is a
an ambitious man on a level we haven't
seen in 100 years your guy general
spalding talks about this and there's
also been other people that you've
interviewed with on the 100 year
marathon xi jinping has accelerated that
progress and he is completely unabashed
in his own
speeches about his plans for for the
future and they they do not include a
world of democratic response to
government
he thinks government
should be in control of everything he
thinks there should be one world
government and it should be his
government under his control uh he
believes in global competence i think
that's great news though let me tell you
why i think that's great news here's why
it's great news say you and i hate each
other we sincerely hate each other we're
enemies whatever you're a real estate
company i'm a real estate we can't stand
each other
you defend uh one guy i defend this guy
that guy's a really bad guy but you keep
defending him okay
so you go in bed with them and try to do
business with them he royally screws you
over
royally which is what's this kind of
thing which this kind of seems like it
then you sit there and say freaking pat
he's not as bad as i thought he was let
me call pat then so he
indirectly got us closer which is a good
thing
so the fact that g is doing that in
china and it's now getting democrats and
republicans to both agree on the fact
that you cannot take china lightly that
is a very important
that's a very good news for america if
we can we can oppose a lot of different
things it's fine but there's one thing
you do not want the left and a right to
not just not agree on and that's china
is that my enemy's enemy is now my ally
was that with that yeah so she
essentially made sorrows defend america
with sorrows
you know his rapture after 20 years of
destabilizing america are you kidding me
soros
is maybe one of the most hated guys in
america on many different lists because
the guy's got power money and he's a
manipulator and literally actively
destabilizing the country no no and he
he's involved in a lot of different
things that he did so so when i saw this
message i'm like what the hell is going
on for saurus
not everything's black and white there's
a lot of gray and and all this like
even in the middle east like even like
you use your syria example
you have the shiites and the sunnis and
then isis and they're fighting al-qaeda
but al-qaeda's not friends in the
taliban
sunni and then actually the in uh the uh
we're friends with these people up here
and then in kashmir they are fighting
with them and it's just like you don't
want to remind you you can't even solve
it remember in uh the last batman movie
the christopher nolan with bane tom
hardy playing bane and then uh you know
the the the businessman thinks that he's
got bane under control and he's like you
get over here and baine's like i'm
already here and he says i've you know
he finally puts his hand on the guy's
shoulder leave oh no don't leave i'm in
control here do you feel in charge and
then the guy realizes in this moment oh
man i made a deal with the devil like
and then you know and he turns to the
guy and he says i paid you a small
fortune and bain looks at him and says
and this gives you power over me
snap and not xi jinping xi jinping is
looking at all these capitalist dummies
saying you know what i've given you but
i love that i've given you 20 years of
power i love that here's why i love that
i love that a person like that reveals
his ambitions publicly because now it
unites
two different parties
i love it because you're on the tv but
but it but listen sorrows has influence
with the left yes they listen to sorrows
so when he says it you have to know like
imagine the people like okay who said it
o'reilly said it it must be right okay
who said it anderson cooper it must be
right okay who said it don lemon he must
be rachel maddow must be right hey tuck
across from us there is that community
so now okay george soros said that china
sucks that's fine i i actually think
this is great now
there's a part of it which you know you
heard what rudy giuliani says well i
supported him for the governorship
because i needed money for funding
that's politics right there you just
heard it right he said that so we don't
know that part of what happened who got
offended who got upset because at that
level when you're a billionaire man
you're most your life you've been
winning a lot of the fights
you've been winning a lot if you're a
billionaire right it's not like you've
been losing you've been winning a lot
you've been losing too but you've been
winning a lot so you're not accustomed
to not being right
so soros maybe
is not happy with somebody we don't know
about yeah jose is 91 years old by the
way but but he is just to put it in
perspective it's not like
he's got big plans for himself like you
said he wants to sit
and be in the inner circle with china's
kids too his kids are just like himself
no i don't i don't know if you you you
what's your point with that no no just
pointing out that's how old he is as old
as yeah but 91 years old if do you
think a guy that gets to his age like
kirk accordion was doing deals at 99
years old before he died i mean john
wooden died at 99 years old at ronald
reagan hospital in l.a so do you think a
guy like that
that you think the fire is missing you
think the fire is not there at all true
believer is the fire missing probably
not are the skills still where they're
at
pull up a picture of george field that
matters
my father that matters
101 was talking about opening up
businesses so when that's in your head
okay it doesn't matter and he made it to
104 103. wow
yeah i mean it's a but by the way what's
the story what happened with fauci and
uh rand paul can you pull up that story
for us to read it there's you talking
about it at dinner last night it came
out i believe it was the intercept that
fauci apparently had uh he lied again
completely lied in which under oath in
congress light again yeah the last time
that that he came out uh it's it's
moments like this where i do wish the
mob was kind of still involved in our
government to be honest with you too uh
rand paul says the new warhand documents
show voucher like can you go up a little
bit to sifa okay yeah generalization of
public documents revealing the extent of
u.s funding coronavirus recently wohan
shows the national institute of allergy
and infectious disease had anthony fauci
lied during his previous testimony to
congress fouchen has adamantly denied
that the national institute of health
funded gain of function research and
wuhan paul blasted fauci in a tuesday
tweet saying that the naid director had
lied again and i was right about his
agency funding novel coronavirus
research at wuhan said rand paul go up a
little bit because of tweets down here
uh rand paul tweet surprise surprise
fouche lied again and i was right about
his agency funding novel coronavirus
research at warren read this thread and
the papers released can you click on
that just to see what that is is it a
formal request to the justice department
to open an investigation let's read this
let's read this so newly released
documents provide detail of u.s funded
research on coronavirus at the one and
survivorology the intercept has obtained
more than 900 pages of document
detailing work of eco-health alliance at
the chinese lab the trova documents
includes two previously unpublished
grant proposals that were funded by the
nia id
as well as the project updates relating
to equal health alliance research which
is scrutinized aimed increased interest
and
materials
the materials revealed that the
resulting novel laboratory generates
sars related coronavirus also could
infect mice engineer to display human
receptors on cells
interesting
so what's going to happen now because
yesterday somebody asked jen saki she
just walked off that's the thing
you asked this question to rudy it was
one of the best questions you would ask
you said if you know these guys
are are corrupt and you have the
evidence all it takes is for one of them
to crack you just need one of them to
crack and the rest of them will fall why
why why is it how how come you know you
talked about omerta how is it that these
guys nobody talks over there and what he
says is that nobody's threatening him so
the mafia never talked until he took all
their stuff away the the racketeering
act you take somebody and you put them
in a large conspiracy and say hey you
may not have done
uh all this but you're attached to the
guys who did all this and are you going
to go away for them but you're right
aren't you seeing what's happening here
trump gets impeached for a phone call
that he made
okay that wasn't anywhere near as
disastrous as the phone call that biden
made to the president of afghanistan and
asked him to lie
straight out lied to the world
and what happens
cricket's out of pelosi nobody wants to
say anything this is such a corrupt
system right now
it's such a double standard that we have
it's disgusting i can't even believe it
if you and i were to do something like
that we'd be doing 100 years
it's terrible what's happening in this
country do you think politicians on both
sides lie
absolutely okay so so let's let's put
that side aside meaning you know uh the
left's gonna lie the right's gonna lie
okay and the left is always gonna show
the one tweeter this guy was lying and
the right is gonna say this guy was
lying okay fine
so
let's say
uh uh oh there is uh
the sinners on both sides and you know
the same people sin in different ways
okay this is where i'm going with this
put that aside
if a person is leading an army if a
person is leading a country if a person
is leading a family okay if a person is
like hey where were you you know i was
with my friends
okay and we were watching the game hey
what were you doing
what is the core
need a country
demands from their leader
forget about the lying part i don't
think we've had a president that hasn't
lied yet okay left right doesn't matter
right
so so number one is safety right okay
great would you agree with that safety
is number one
keep the country safe okay so i don't
care what you're saying what you're
spewing out because sometimes you know
we have pride we're like well you know
no no no no no maybe over exaggerated
you know i don't think anybody's gonna
be uh uh innocent of that right okay
are we getting safety what's next out of
safety i would say justice okay so
justice fine what is after justice so
justice is a form of safety to me by the
way because justice provides me to know
that a bigger guy is not going to bully
me because i know law and order is going
to protect that's something i got to be
honest with you i've lost faith in over
the last 10 years i do not believe that
we are all operating under the same set
of rules i i think somebody your
political affiliation
is going to determine whether you're
innocent or guilty not the actual
committing of the crime how can you hold
one party accountable to one person
accountable to something and let the
other one go with the same crime
you know patrick this country is going
crazy i am a former criminal do you know
that in san francisco now they are
paying criminals not to shoot other
people what i don't pay their money 300
bucks
yeah but that's not new what's going on
in san francisco
how long that's where nancy pelosi and
kamala harris are from and dianne
feinstein three of the most powerful
people in our government are from san
francisco that's their home
one of the greatest cities in the world
what i'm saying i use the biden trump
thing because how could you hold
somebody
so accountable for something that they
did and somebody did something even more
grievous and you just crickets you let
it go yeah what's going on in this
country is the double standard is
horrible the justice department can't be
politicized man it just can't be it is
it is 100 percent and
again bring this up and i don't care who
it is hunter biden's laptop
draw it if you and i had information
just the stuff that we've heard forget
about what else might be on there we
would be doing a hundred year you would
be in jail with no bail you'd be doing a
hundred years
too and everybody forgets about that one
well i mean
this is the president's son who was
using his father's political power to
ingratiate himself into and i mean you
ca and it's right out in the open has it
been going on of course but this is
right out in the open you have to act on
stuff like this
and they're letting it go otherwise
people who's letting it go and your
opinion what do you think they should do
and i'm not a hunter biden fan i just
it's not like it's not in the news it's
not like they can't go after them you
should do something about it obviously
justice joe biden's not going to do
anything about it the justice department
okay
we talk about we talk about january 6th
and how serious that was and that there
was a january january 6th commission
there were hundreds of riots where
people actually died billions of dollars
of damage you know they take over
portland they take over the city of
portland america you know nothing's done
you know what the biggest insult and
slap in the face i don't know if you've
watched uh you know the recent thing on
9 11 the documentary with uh condoleezza
rice and all those guys yeah all of that
what do you think about it i thought it
was great okay what's his name the uh
the black film producer uh did it what's
it tyler perry no not time
spike spikedly spiked
it's bro yeah you got to watch it it's
it'll make it
is it one-sided or no no it'll make you
cry he did a brilliant job okay
he's a good filmmaker but no no here's
the thing yeah
yeah yeah no i i didn't like yeah i get
it i want to see what michael we all
remember the devastation of that day we
all remember no question there was
nothing like it ever in our lifetime
for these people aoc and some of these
people to compare what happened on
january 6
to what happened on 911 is is the most
disgusting thing i have ever heard 3 000
lives lost
a city the worst thing that ever
happened compared you know other than uh
pearl harbor and that was at least all
military
and for them to say that january 6 was
worse than 9 11
a.o.c
they're treating it worse than what yes
and pelosi these people just say these
things are not not held accountable to
it
it's an insult to everybody whatever
side you're on the aisle that's just
doesn't matter what yeah it doesn't it's
not dumb it's not dumb it's worse than
dome
you don't see you know what it's so
dark and divisive and it's offensive i
would put all of that and she lives in
new york
yeah but you have to realize again
respect the the enemy has to get respect
for her knowing how to move
naive people who
are looking to find a person that they
hate because of whatever reasons right
like
one of the guys i'm interviewing right
now that we put on the list yesterday
you know he again another guy that's a
communist who hates capitalism because
capitalists make a lot of money and it's
not fair i'm like i can't wait to talk
to guys like this these are the types of
guys i want to talk to
they're convincing
they get people to say this makes sense
like aoc is very very convincing
she's got you know
you have to know i'm telling you right
now there's a 10 to 20 percent chance
aoc is going to be president united
states one day 10 to 20. uh
you're saying lower or higher
oh my god
lower or higher please be lower okay i'm
willing to bet i'm willing to bet right
now she stays alive she stays healthy
i'm willing to bet she's going to be a
president she's got another 40 years
let me tell you she's doing something
that roger stone said the most important
thing for somebody to be a real
candidate is what relevance is relevancy
and eyeballs yeah he's by the way like
logan paul that's a qualified guy that
could be a president next 20 years you
can hate logan paul all you want that
guy is going to be a candidate to run
for presidency once again
well it's like who's the girl that you
even brought up her name the girl the
governor of uh christie nell okay never
heard of her we talked politics all day
long i've never heard of her name she's
amazing she says never heard her name
zero relevancy so we've all heard of
yeah you know i'm getting easier and
easier
to be sold on joe manchin joe manchin is
doing doing something i've been calling
for john he's going to run i don't know
if he's going to run
i don't think that's in his uh he should
though i don't think he's going to run i
don't think that's something that by the
way let's talk about a story that has to
do with what just happened this week
regarding your former boss
you know story came out with the fact
that you know
uh legendary colombo boss carmine junior
persico was a top echelon fbi informant
court records say wow you know story
came out you dealt with them directly
you spend time with them
how much credence you give to this
article this story that article was
insulting it was fabrication i don't
believe it in any way shape or form
daily news should be ashamed of
themselves for putting that on a front
page with a picture of a rat listen
i knew i knew junior very well he was no
informant he was no rat you know i hate
that you know patrick i hate the term
rat because
you know all the internet warriors now
they throw that around like they know
what they're talking about you know and
uh it's a disgrace to even say that
about the guy and listen
i mean he was my boss he also put a
contract on my life when i walked away
you know so he he wasn't happy with that
with that move but
uh
absolute
absolute nonsense i'll read it to you it
says official boss of the colombo uh
family on uh whose side greg scarpa the
colombo capo fbi informant and roy
lindley uh de vicio scarpa's fbi handler
were working carmine persico was himself
since decades earlier in the
government's employ as a member of its
top echelon informant program wrote
attorney david shone who submitted a
document in july in a brooklyn federal
court filing aiming at getting his
client one-time acting car uh colombo
boss victor or arena 87 we should spend
a lot of time talking about him 87 out
of prison on compassionate release
persico died in 2019 at 85
he served 32 years of his 136-year
probation a prison sentence following
his conviction in the mafia commission
case so
you're saying there's zero credence to
him being a rat no what they're saying
there is greg scarpa who we know was an
informant for 20 some odd years
might have been trying to maybe he got
some information out of persico
personally didn't know that uh he was an
informant
you know scarpa so maybe some things
coming from persico were going through
scarpa to the government not with
persecutors knowledge you didn't know
that by the way kai do you have the
chinchigante comment from uh uh from uh
uh uh uh what do you call it rudy if
you're not from what sammy and michael
said because but rudy said something
different about the chin i don't know if
you have it is this the one or it's a
different one
this is the one okay so we talked about
chin and you know chin's of power all
that stuff rudy had a different thought
i'm curious to know what you have to say
about what rudy said if you want to play
kai
we were going to do a big raid
and we were going to arrest the number
one or number two people in each family
they did that about two weeks before
well chen giganti
who thought he was number two in the
japanese family but he wasn't
because everybody hated him
they told him he was number two he was
like number eight
chin is the guy who walked around in the
robes and acted like he was crazy well
he was crazy
he was a
borderline personality disorder in the
military he was actually i think
officially
officially uh diagnosed as a paranoid
schizophrenic he was yeah somebody but
he played that he played it up
so
this information comes out
one of the issues comes in until the
unit you have to believe this
chin checked himself in austin
he thinks we're going to arrest him
can be very disappointed when we don't
read
did you end up with the award eventually
but not for that i got it we're not for
that so it it it displayed to the whole
world they've been they've been lying to
him for several years tell you send your
number two you're number two now
wow fat tony knew he was nuts so he made
him think he was number two but he never
he said how come i don't go to the oh
come on i don't go to the
to the to the commission meetings i'm
number two they say you know chin you're
too high profile
with that bad throat but all that stuff
if they see you walking in they'll know
where we're having the meetings
thoughts i have to disagree with that
really yes why is that kai can you pull
up a picture of this guy
shinjukanti shin was number one chin was
number one absolutely he was the real
power behind the jenna beast family did
you ever have a dealing with him or i
did how was he as an individual
you know
we walked down houston street together
and uh he was in his bathrobe hair
mussed up he didn't shave go back
slippers bathroom but he was as lucid
and as intelligent as anybody could be
you know my father was thrown out in the
military being a military being paranoid
schizophrenic with homicidal tendencies
now was my dad maybe the homicidal
tendencies but but he wasn't
schizophrenic uh so listen you know
people ask me all the time was chin
really you know goofy and
listen to play goofy for 30 years you've
got to have a little bit of craziness in
you but he was he was sharp as a do
you think that was a ruse he was putting
on a ruse 100 percent really 100
100 ruche
they have hours and hours and hours of
taps in this so he they
explain how that guy could get that that
wrong he
i don't know where he got that
information from i don't know and look
even fat tony i mean fat tony was the
boss but he consulted with chin all the
time
michael let me ask you you said uh your
boss put a contract out on your life yes
so there's a two-part question
what does that mean actually in reality
and what was the most
most you feared for your life in your
entire years of being in the mob
well because i walked away from the life
i basically betrayed my oath and
personal put a hit out on me i mean the
feds told me that they said my father
went along with it you know i mean i had
all of that when i was in prison that's
why they locked me down they put me in
administrative detention
but um
let me tell you the deal you know one of
the one of the horrors of that life adam
you make a mistake your best friend
walks you into a room you don't walk out
again your best friend your best friend
or somebody close to you obviously
unsuspecting right you walk into a room
you don't walk out well i had that
experience one night
and if you want you know i can take a
minute to describe it i it was all gas
business stuff a story came out i
believe it was a news day i'm not
positive that said that i was getting
powerful enough to break away from the
colombos and start my whole family total
nonsense it was ridiculous it was
fiction
there was no semblance of reality to it
but uh you know i started real quick how
does something like that become news is
there like a competitor that decides
we're going to screw with michael or
let's let's you know leak something you
know sometimes reporters just create i
mean i can tell you so many stories that
there was just no truth to them they
just create these things you know i was
pretty high profile i was getting a lot
of attention and um
so guys you know on the street you hey
you know anyway he's turning in this
amount of money maybe there's more you
know it said i was making two billion
dollars that was not true
and so
you know persico started uh you know
questioning some of my russian
partners and you know word was going
around on the street so
my dad uh was out on parole and he calls
me up and he said look we got to go to a
meeting i go to his house we're in the
driveway speaking he says
junior wants to see us tonight i said
okay it's what time you want me to pick
you up because my dad was on parole he
only traveled with me because i tried to
keep him safe
and he said mike they want this a little
bit differently they want me to come in
first they want you to come in second
long story short i was a poet i said dad
you know to talk on the street why
they're going to let them separate us
let's go together we were both captains
at that point in time
we argued about it in the driveway i
think i might have told you this patrick
and i said you know what dad i don't
agree with you but i've been listening
to you all my life if that's what you
want fine
so um
i drive in it was late at night we had
to meet junior in a house in brooklyn
because it was a covert meeting he was
on parole didn't want to get violated so
jimmy angelina
was another captain at family uh i meet
him in brooklyn he says get in my car
we're gonna drive to where the meeting
is
i get in the car there's somebody
sitting in the back seat
i recognized him but i didn't know
really who he was jimmy don't even
introduce me i get in the car
and um he's very close-mouthed he's not
really talking you know he starts
talking about the yankees you know i'm a
die-hard yankee i didn't want to hear
about the yankees that night
we get to the house in brooklyn
it was late at night and it was about a
30 yard walk from the car to the
basement apartment that we had to go
into
and i get out of the car
i'm assuming jimmy's behind me and maybe
the other guy behind him
and i'll be honest i'm getting scared i
said this is this is a bad setup what's
going on here now i'm thinking
everything's going through my head i'll
be honest with you
when i recount this
i can i can smell the fragrance it was
an august night
and i can hear the crickets chirping
that's how real this was yes
and i'm i'm walking down those steps and
uh i'm scared i mean my knees are
starting to buckle i mean it because
when that door opens i said the last
thing i'm going to see got to understand
i mean i've i've been around since you
were keenly aware of it at that moment
very aware why didn't you run you didn't
you know people have asked me michael
why didn't you cut and run and
it wasn't heroic it was robotic
you just become so much a product of
that life you say well this is it this
is it you know and that's what i
honestly thought
you know i walk in the door obviously
i'm here because if it would have went
the other way i would have walked in the
door would have been over but
so we have this whole big thing in there
questioning me about the gas business
and so on and so forth and i started
getting mad
i started getting angry because you
gotta understand i'm turning in a lot of
money a lot of money
and and this was my deal i mean i put it
together
and uh but then i said wait a minute i'm
here with the boss let me calm down you
know it looks like i'm gonna walk out of
here
and we get in the car
and you know
i was really angry with jimmy i turned
to him and i was uh really your friend
was my good friend
and he said stop wait don't say anything
i said what he said you know you held
yourself pretty good in there tonight
michael this could have been a real
problem
and so now i got even more mad i said
you knew this
you're my friend i know you my whole
life you don't tell me anything
so he looked at me he was smart guy and
he said if it was the other way around
would you have told
and i thought about it and i said no
damn
he said you know he says this is the
life we live michael he said you know it
as well as anybody you grew up in it
and uh and then i walked out of the car
i don't know if i ever told you this as
i i didn't know what to say i was kind
of speechless for a minute i go to get
out of the car and he grabs my arm and
he says to me i'm going to tell you
something you're not going to want to
hear this but it's the truth michael i
said what he said your father was in
there before you tonight he didn't help
you one bit
okay with that in mind well here's what
happened yes i'm walking back to the car
and i'm saying what what could my then
now that's all i was focused on what
could my dad could have done but knowing
him so well i know what he did
hey my son does everything i'm on parole
if he's stealing money i have no i he
just threw me under the bus he didn't
back me up why at all i don't know why
i'll be honest i don't know why i never
said a word to him about this i just
kept it and never brought it
no i never said a word but when i was
writing my first book
i put it in the book
i had to it was too much of an impact on
my life
because i'll tell you this if that
incident did not happen
i don't think i would have ever walked
away from the life it was my dad's
betrayal in that regard now he denied it
that's not true he denied it but i knew
it was true
but if i said to myself this if this
life can separate father and son what do
we really have here
but the point being is after that
experience
nothing really scared me wow so what i
did when i left the life i said okay
they're not going to walk me into a room
i'm moving to california
i said they're not they're gonna have to
send a hit squad to come and get me and
i'm prepared i'm not gonna walk my dog
at the same time every morning i'm not
gonna go to the same restaurant i'm
gonna stay out of clubs i'm gonna be
very disciplined they're gonna have to
work hard to get me so i never was in
fear after that time
i just was careful
and you talk about respect and loyalty a
lot right
but
is there any trust or even friendship in
this life you know there is i had i had
friends and i had you know i trusted in
people but you gotta you gotta
understand something
when a boss gives you an order it
doesn't matter
that's it i mean look i had an
experience i had a very dear friend of
mine that got killed
and i believe he got killed for the
wrong reasons and i could not save him
and they warned me they said if you want
him you're in trouble
and you know i mean i still live with
that today that's a horrible horrible
thing
but
that's the thing the oath comes before
anything and if you're given an order
you've got to do it or you suffer for it
well michael yeah you know and i really
apologize if this comes off as
disrespectful so forgive me but i mean
how could you ever look at your father
the same way i mean how could you ever i
mean you're a father you're you just had
your fourth child is there anything in
the world
where you wouldn't take me instead like
my god like why would you what would
ever cause you that's that's why
sunny
the guy did 55 years he didn't need to
do 55 years
sonny could have easily worked with
anybody and you
you're not dealing with a regular guy
you're dealing with a true believer
mafia like mobster like that's my
opinion i think you may say part of it
that's a true believer but
it sounds like a religious history
articles written about sonny are very
different than anybody else patrick let
me tell you this about my dad this is
the truth and i and listen i love my dad
i love him like forget it you know so
but but i'm telling the truth about him
my dad's legacy in that life meant more
to him than anything that's what i'm
saying yeah he just wanted to be known
as the stand-up guy now you know all the
good things he said to you about those
guys when he talked to me
this life is full of michael i mean
he would tell me just like that you
gotta why oh yeah life is like a wheel
it's gonna turn the guy that loves you
today he's gonna hate you tomorrow we
would go through and he educated me
which was great good feedback with some
of that great great
whatever he told me was spot-on there's
no doubt about it but i had a i had a
conversation with my dad once you know
and i said dad
you know
you don't understand you destroyed the
whole family he got very insulted i said
my mom 33 years without her husband's
your basket case my sister dies of an
overdose of drugs 27 years old my
brother drug addict 25 years turns into
an informant
you got to claim some responsibility for
this you said no way i was framed if i
wasn't framed none of this would have
happened i said but dad you weren't
framed because you were a doctor a
lawyer or a priest yeah this is the life
we lived they're coming after us and you
sacrificed your entire family he got
very upset he probably got upset because
he's very upset you were you were close
to the bullseye he got very upset with
me he would never accept responsibility
and and that's what kind of
you know i was always when my mom and
dad had a very
chaotic relationship they always back
and forth they loved each other but it
was always a lot of hostility in the
house
and i would always side with my dad
always side with my dad and then towards
the end of my mom's life i started to
listen to her a little bit i started to
see things a little differently so when
i would approach my dad with that he
would get upset with me
michael for those of us that have no
clue about this we're on time i have one
other topic i want to go with so if you
want to wrap this up i got one other
question i got for you but please if you
want to wrap up
no so you know look i mean i love my dad
to leanne but we had a difference
i mean that that really impacted me
obviously you know that that whole
situation so it was just different
between us more power to you for being
you've been married now for how many
years 37 37 years
five kids you have seven total yes right
your family is happy they love you you
see them wanting to be around you that's
the biggest
way to judge a father or a parent if the
kids still love the dad after 20 30
years their pops and moms they did some
right if they want to be around them so
that props goes to you
but i'm telling you when you from my
experience when i was spending those
three days with your dad those three
times that we were with him very
different i've not met many people like
him he was a fully like true believer
like a
general like a jack nicholson from a few
good men that's like what are you
talking about this is
like to that point of conviction duty
yeah very beautiful very dutiful to him
now listen that doesn't mean other
people believe that that doesn't mean
you know you live that life that just
means that's how his
question for about two characters i'm
curious to know if you have anything to
say about this one is johnny russo one
is john a light both of them have been
on valuetainment both of them have
gotten millions of views john a light
you know he's you know especially right
now with the interview taking place
mafia states of america there's a lot of
people making videos
they're happy some are not happy some
are calling you out some are calling
michael there's a lot some are calling
sammy out
what what what what can you say from
your experience you guys were both in
the was it rip city new york uh i don't
know what that documentary
city both of you guys were rip cities
i'm thinking about the porn yeah so what
what what is your point of view of
john a lot everywhere i go when i run
into albanians they adore they admire
him what can you say about john
patrick i never met the guy i never
heard of the guy i never knew anything
about him until he came up on social
media for some reason he decided to make
comments about me
um again i don't know anybody that knew
him i don't know anything about him
and i've always said to myself i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna make my name by
knocking other people
i'm gonna leave it at that i have really
nothing to say about him how about
gianni how about johnny russo
johnny rousseau
i mean he's almost a comedy act i mean
this guy has done everything in in in
the history of the united states and
beyond i never met him either i don't
know anything about him he says a lot of
things that happened you know during the
making of the godfather i was around i
never seen him i'm not saying he didn't
show up but i think a lot of the things
that he's saying are just uh he's an
actor
what more can i say
i mean some of the stories is just
by the way another great storyteller of
what he's yeah i'm unfamiliar with it
like
he said something about how to go watch
it like saddam hussein he sat in the
same chair as saddam hussein stuff he
did with the shah uh
stuff and by the way the way he tells a
story it's so detailed that's like
you know it's extremely detailed on how
he tells i told him when i sat down with
him i said johnny first of all i enjoy
being around you because you're so
entertaining i said but if ten percent
of the stories you're telling me is true
you'll live the ridiculous life he's
he's the mafia forest gump is that the
uh
he said one story about joe colombo
blowing up the gates of paramount
studios and that would be huge news i
never heard that happen ever you know
and i was around during the whole
colombo godfather thing you know when it
was being i never heard any of that
spoke very high of your props very
highly of your public you know who he
was and you know what he had to say i
doubt my father ever met him okay
got it so so let's just do this because
because mafia states of america it's
going to come out here soon we don't
know the dates we're going to reveal it
and who knows maybe even we
end up doing a live event together with
me you sammy chaz who knows maybe rudy
at the fountain uh blue in south florida
and invite and you know tickets i don't
that would be an interesting live event
if we did something like that so maybe
after all the episodes are live and
people have seen it then maybe we may do
something live it's not not everyone's
going to be able to 10 because that
place only fits about 800 but i can only
imagine what types of people would come
that and the kind of security we're
going to need for us to conduct that
thing but the first thing that we are i
want to show you this so this is a
coffee mug that says mafia states of
america and here's how it works when
you're having the coffee
and you put your coffee in there or your
tea this is what happens to the mug
which is pretty cool
i don't know if it's happening yet or
not oh yeah i see an image yes yeah
gradually
the image comes out that is cool that is
pretty cool on mafia states of america
and the longer it sits
the more evident it becomes with the mug
where you see literally the thumbnail
of our sit down so this water is not
that hot i'm putting my finger and it's
not burning but so it's sammy and i are
the same yeah so it's the mug comes out
with you and sammy it's literally
i'm going to hold it here so folks can
see it
so before i did this
wait when you get to the gas business
did you ever think you'd have your own
merch
never you're gonna bring your clothes so
first it looked like this wow just the
black coffee mug then you put the hot
water the hot tea or the coffee in it
next thing you know sammy shows up
michael shows up
with uh mafia states of america it's
really really cool yeah that's cool yeah
it's really cool who came up with this
idea well the guy who did it you know
we've done some work with them but we uh
uh set this up kai and mario dealt with
them put it together so it's pretty
exciting for folks who'd like to get
this coffee mug
we're gonna put the link below uh kai
put the link below both in the
description and in the chat box for
people to find it i think at this point
we're gonna sell it later on but at this
point the first hundred are gonna be
able to all order one the first hundred
that placed the order you're gonna get
that much shipped out to you we don't
have a big supply today we will once we
launch the whole thing but right now the
first 100 if you click on the link to
order it you'll get your first uh
limited edition uh mafia of this year
amy and i get one free yeah we're gonna
give that to you that you don't have to
pay for anything but we're excited about
this thing coming out michael uh as
usual uh you always have an interesting
take on
any topic we go on i think you're one
that you can talk sports you can talk
politics you can talk business you can
talk mob you can talk history there's
not many topics that we can talk to i
think the only thing we can't talk to
michael about is uh snowboarding skiing
cold weather that's the only thing you
have no desire to discuss none
whatsoever gang if you listen to this if
you enjoy today's interview smash that
subscribe button and the thumbs up
button we're going to put michael's
information below as well if you want to
go send him a message and follow him on
instagram as well as his youtube channel
if you've not followed his youtube
channel it's a must watch it's a must
subscribe to his channel all that
information will be below michael once
again thanks for coming on being on the
podcast thank you very much appreciate
you this was great thank you
you